well
they said they weren't coming for your
guns but they're coming for your guns
and for a while now i've been talking
about these articles and things i've
read
that allude to a second civil war courts
cold civil war
and one thing i often hear from people
is like tim nothing's going to happen in
la in that capacity until they come for
your guns
and i was like bro joe biden's going to
come for your guns beto o'rourke said it
well today joe biden asserted that
constitutional amendments are not
absolute which is technically correct
but he said that in order to justify his
executive action
on gun control which you cannot do
now look i got to be honest i think this
are these executive orders will get
struck down the supreme court's going to
throw them out
but the guy's clearly trying to do it
and we're probably going to see red flag
legislation
from congress and a lot of these people
these establishment liberal types
like not even the socialist type
socialist types they like the guns but
these these run-of-the-mill liberals
have no idea what they're talking about
when it comes to these laws and it's
going to get bad for everybody
it's going to result in unintended
consequences and what's really happening
in my opinion is that joe biden is
throwing red meat to a bunch of regular
like uninitiated politically ignorant
people who have no idea what's going on
these these rules and regulations will
do nothing but cause suffering and harm
and uh we're going to talk about what
joe biden said because he pushed several
misconceptions about our constitutional
rights he said you can't yell fire in a
crowded theater you can
he said back when the second amendment
you know was made you couldn't buy
whatever gun you wanted that's also
incorrect privateers were a thing for a
long time and actually fact check all
that
so we're gonna get into it we got a
bunch of other stories too jordan
peterson is embracing the memes
about red skull and it's hilarious
because the people are now taking
red skull images this nazi villain and
putting jordan peterson quotes on them
and i think it's fantastic so we
actually have a really great guest who
can talk to us about all of these things
we have former special forces jim hansen
also
author do you want to introduce yourself
a little bit yeah i guess the book we're
going to talk about tonight one of them
is winning the second civil war without
firing a shot
and uh that kind of implies that if need
be
we could fire a shot the goal is to
avoid that
and i think the idea now you said we're
not we can't have a second civil war
until they come for the guns well they
are
and they're going to and they have some
high constitutional hurdles
is the fortunate thing justice scalia
before he died
did the republic a massive favor by
writing the dc versus heller opinion
which codified an individual right to
own a weapon
irrespective of any militia service and
that that weapon
should be in common use and useful for
service in a militia
what kind of gun do you think a foot
soldier in the militia would carry these
days
i think an ar-15 is exactly it and so
did scalia
i i've got one correction for you hit me
we're in a second civil war
the idea is just that people expect it
to be exactly what happened you know
100 plus years ago whatever what it's
going to look like it's going to be new
weapons going to be new methods new
technology
and the reason i say it this way is it
was a princeton professor
who said we're in a cold civil war this
was this was published on the hill
and all these lefties are like tim poole
is the one asserting this bro i'm just
reading the news
right so we're in it we're in this
conflict and a lot of people
i i'll tell you this i know we're going
to get a little in the weeds but it's
supposed to be the intro but we had ryan
long on you know ryan long the comedian
yeah and he was like so the first thing
he does in the intro he's like so tim
where's the civil war
you had me freaked out and i was like on
january 6 a bunch of people stormed in
the capital and he went
oh yeah what about all last year be a
lemon antifa
killed dozens injured hundreds of cops
caused two billion dollars worth of
damage
seized government buildings some of them
for weeks on end
in seattle they had a police station for
more than weeks if that's not an
insurrection
i don't know what one is and i do know
what one is
just washington dc everything else was
ignored by the media that was that was a
protest
wasn't it garland who was like well it
wasn't terrorism because it was at night
garland's a disgrace here's the thing we
have to have one set of rules all right
if you want to say that there were some
people who went to the capitol
who actually had insurrection in mind
there were it was less than a handful
yeah but there were people who did that
the rest of them were glorified
trespassers
well and right and there's videos of the
doors being opened by the cops we'll get
into all that stuff so uh you also have
a book
about white fragility was it the myth of
white for julian i think so we've got uh
we got some stories relating to cancel
culture comics wokeness we'll get into
all that as well
so glad to have you man we also got ian
he's chillin yes ian from ian
crossland.net
and i think we are not in a civil war
so i think this will be a wonderful
debate from all angles and i'm very
very excited to hear your pull down your
thoughts and feelings on that journey in
the future
yeah they're fixing the mic over there
yeah i just kept talking louder and
slower
you're just getting louder and louder
slowly accelerating
uh yeah i'm sorry patch liz i'm really
excited about this conversation because
my boss is so into the whole civil war
thing
and i'm excited for the positivity and
optimism
right on well before we get started my
friends make sure you go over to
timcast.com and become a member why we
have a bunch of exclusive members only
segments
from the tim cast irl podcast you can
see we got we had brandon tatum last
night and i misspelled his name as
brayden tatum but
even better just click it figure out who
that guy is and we had seamus we had
josie
uh redhead libertarian michael malus
these are conversations you'll only be
able to get full podcast episodes in
some instances
at timcast.com and when you become a
member you're helping to support this
show in the event that we get banned or
purged we'll still have a place
to produce content and bring it to you
so hopefully it doesn't happen
but look at what they're doing with
steven crowder so i think it's only a
matter of time we got to do what we can
to build up our own independent networks
and also smash the like button subscribe
notification bell if you're listening on
itunes or spotify or any podcast
platform leave us a good review
give us five stars give a good comment
and ultimately all of you can just share
this show if you really like it because
that's the best way to actually help
let's jump into this first story we'll
talk about gun control
biden says no amendment in the
constitution
is absolute and calls gun violence a
public health crisis
and embarrassment as he prepares to sign
six executive orders
cracking down on firearms there's two
things i want to highlight as we start
this conversation
he says nothing about i'm about to
recommend in any way
impinges on the second amendment you
mean infringes
yeah he didn't say that word oh boy
these are phony arguments
suggesting that these are second
amendment rights at stake no amendment
to the constitution is absolute by and
declared
and then he points to the famous supreme
court ruling from i think it's 1919
that you can't yell fire in a crowded
theater and that was shank uh as part of
the first amendment's free speech clause
which is wrong because in brandenburg v
ohio i believe was
1969 they ruled actually you can yell
fire in a crowded theater joe biden has
to know i'm assuming he knows that or
he's a [ __ ]
i'm assuming he knows it because he has
legal experts who actually helped craft
these executive order policies
he wouldn't be saying stupid garbage
unless he's trying to mislead people
because this is what they do ori hadn't
had his nap yet and he might have been a
little slow
that's that's that's fair point
absolutely i would like to point out
impinge is a word
i know that is all i was saying he's not
saying infringe
because that's actually what's in the
constitution yeah i see
right right he's getting cheeky the
right to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed
but but impinged i guess you could it it
works i'm just saying
shall be impinged he didn't want to get
too close to actually using the language
that
people go oh i see what you're doing
check this out he said from the very
beginning you couldn't own any weapon
you wanted to own that's a lie
and from the very beginning of the
second amendment existed certain people
weren't allowed to have weapons
so the idea is just bizarre to suggest
that some of the things we're
recommending are contrary to the
constitution
so here's what's going to happen you you
get these lies over and over again
the first thing i'm going to say studies
have found liberals
on twitter for the most part only follow
liberals whereas conservatives follow
both conservatives and liberals
it has changed a little bit for the most
for the most part though it is still
true
and the other thing we see is that
liberals get about
about 95 percent of their news from
liberal sources moderates get 60
of their news they get about two-thirds
from liberal and one-third from
conservative and conservatives are
inverted getting about two-thirds from
conservative
and one-third from liberal news sources
what this means is that people we call
liberals are in bubbles
they don't have any idea what's actually
going on outside that bubble and then
you get the media
telling them lies so now people are
going to hear this over and over and
over again
you can't yell fire in a crowded theater
see free speeches limits
okay well you're wrong that's that was
overruled and i think 1969.
then they say you couldn't own any gun
you wanted to usa today
fact checked this and a bunch of
historians were like there actually
weren't really any laws limiting the
right of private cities
private citizens and private citizens in
the revolutionary war era from owing
from owning military-grade weapons
cannons artillery grape shot all that
stuff and then when they talk about
yeah well you you the muzzle uh
muzzleloaded rifles muskets took a
minute to reload
yes and they had volley guns since since
1339 i think a volley gun
is when they have a bunch of different
barrels all loaded and you have one
trigger pole which fires all of them off
which is fully automatic
so but it is wrong he is outright
denying our constitutional rights in
order to justify his executive orders
which violates the constitution
so moving moving into this bigger
conversation we'll get about talking
about guns and about second civil war
and all that stuff
a lot of people have said you know they
view second civil war or civil war as
like factions marching down the street
i don't think that's what it'll look
like i think it'll be more like
insurgency if it does get to the point
of violence but we've already seen proud
boys and antifa and right-wing election
groups clash
but more importantly it's a cold civil
war and this is one of the elements of
it
telling you your rights don't exist and
then passing executive orders
that's despotic trump the worst thing
trump did was the bump stock ban
because that was not now i think the
supreme court i'm sorry there
one court has ruled i think it was what
the ninth district i could be wrong
that bomb stocks are not machine guns so
that may actually get overturned
but they complain all day about donald
trump's executive orders well here's joe
biden
well and here's the thing when you talk
about a civil war okay
shooting in the streets happened already
all right so we have had that
but what about information warfare which
we are constantly bombarded with what
about the fact that like you said
the constitutional rights are being
trampled upon
in a way that if if the left was
actually trying to spark an insurrection
what would they do differently all right
they're isolating us
on social media and shutting down our
right to speech
they're trying to disarm us they have
declared whiteness
to be a an evil thing so they're
othering
an entire large segment of the
population
and they're they're using police powers
against us they're refusing to let the
police
help people during the riots they
actually had the police called off
what would they do different if they
weren't actually trying to turn this
into a hot war
so would you consider what mao did with
the communist cultural revolution
uh a civil war a chinese civil war that
probably more on the purge side from him
you know because that was that was
using police state powers against it i
think we're still empowered enough as
conservatives or people of the right
whatever you consider yourself i mean
i'm a libertarian conservative even
moderates even
i'm not a particularly conservative
person the interesting thing is that i
get labeled conservative for simply
telling the truth
and not being a statist so if you're an
anti-statist
you automatically get lumped on that
side of the political space
this is the craziest thing about it is
that this subject matter you discuss
determines whether you're left or right
not your political policies because i've
had
we had we had jack murphy and michael
mouse in here and i got arguments about
the wealthy and their ability to
influence elections with dumping massive
amounts of money and i said i'm against
it
i don't think these people should have
this much power much more traditionally
left position
those you're you're not going to see
these grifters on social media take
those clips of me screaming like
these billionaires and millionaires are
you know
are manipulating our elections they
don't want to show that because then i'm
not right-wing anymore and they need me
to be
well and the the dividing line is not
right or left as much as it is statist
or libertarian individualist if you
believe you can best determine what you
should be doing
as long as you're not hurting other
people then you're on my team
if you believe the state or the solons
of the woke left
know better than you how to live your
life and what you should do then you're
on the other team and you're my enemy
and i don't mind saying you're my enemy
because they're trying to
to push us out of polite society they're
trying to criminalize conservatism or
the ideas
that they find offensive and i find that
offensive
right and you but i'll tell you this ian
brings a good point about china
because uh you know ian asks about what
mao did you say it's more of a purge
and i thought to myself you know what
you're right maybe it's not a second
civil war because conservatives for the
most part are fighting it
well but we need to and that's why i
wrote the book for one reason and
and the problem with the right is that
we to oh eagles don't flock you know i'm
not going to be part of a movement or do
anything
so they can pick us off one by one so
they can do things like let twitter shut
us down like
you guys were looking for my twitter
account tonight guess what you can't
find it
because they grade me out they put a
sensitive filter so you can't even find
me by name
because they don't like what i say i
haven't violated their rules yeah not a
single one and they
they banned uh josie the redheaded
libertarian for literally no reason no
little libertarian account you know she
interacts she's a friend of ours
and they just deleted her it's in their
terms of service they can ban anyone for
no reason
and they will it's a social media credit
score and they're doing that they're to
how they do it what algorithms they're
using to
to actually do it i don't know but it's
obvious they're doing it
because i haven't violated i haven't
gotten a single strike
and yet my you don't even see my face
you know you see grayed out
profile picture when you go to my
twitter feed look the social credit
system is legit
they they might not have a legitimate
score or algorithm that calculates it
but we know it's real like you're the
wrong kind of person with the wrong
opinions and then all of a sudden you
start getting banned from different
platforms if you don't break the rules
you start getting suppressed and shadow
banned
and then they ultimately ban you if your
opinions are bad and that's why
we got to stand up that's why the people
who are not status not totalitarian
unwoke based
white pillars whatever we want to be i
don't care but we got to band together
against it and stand up and say no
so how do we prevent a purge and a civil
war
without firing a shot the first thing
you got to do
is stand up and fight because too many
people on the right have been complacent
we were focused on other things it's one
of the things i talk about in the book
the right thought that if we just focus
on foreign policy and national security
and business and then the the
constitution will keep us safe
they can't take that away can they and
we found out we were wrong
well define fight fight in the
figurative term
and let me give you how about let's do
it but i mean like uh sorry i i didn't
think you meant literally go physically
fight people
just like what would a person have to do
to be engaged in this this cultural
battle yeah but first let me
let's give the disclaimer so that when
people come after you they don't blame
you for my book
neither tim nor i want a civil war or an
insurrection and this is a no
way be considered to be a call for
anything
like that not a dog whistle or anything
else you losers
now figuratively how we can fight is by
banding together and standing up
and we have to actually change our focus
we never used to do that
did conservatives go to pta meetings you
know did we get involved in state and
local politics
no we didn't think we had to we thought
that the constitution of first amendment
second amendment were sacrosanct
they're not they're they're coming for
us so if they're coming for us we have
to play the same game
and like andrew breitbart said war these
people are evil
they are i look i i i grew up with this
very pragmatic
you know very middle of the road view i
was pretty far left when i was younger
and i always had this this this view
where it's like there's no real good or
evil everyone's the hero of their own
story
and now as i'm older you start to really
see it and experience it
it's an interesting thing you hear a lot
from people about how
when they get older they start to become
they start to believe more in a higher
power more faith-based especially when
they have kids i'm not i'm not getting
religious i'm just saying
man you really start to understand what
evil is once you get older you get
involved in politics you see what these
people do
the the number one example that really
just like
was when i when i heard this one thing
that's when my heart sank and i was like
wow i have been too nice to people it
was when aoc
referred to the child detention centers
as influx facilities
with controversial records she spends
what during the trump administration
concentration camp
over and over and over again trump shut
down the homestead facility
biden reopened it an aoc who had called
it a concentration camp
today says influx facility with
controversial record i was like
wow so that was what are you going to
wear she can wear
black this time is versus the white
outfits you got to have a different
outfit because it's a different
administration understand the simplest
thing which you just
outlined everybody they will say
whatever they have to
because they're just after power they
want power to tell everyone what to do
because they don't believe people make
the decisions
that they believe need to be made and
they think it's a question of good and
evil
like you said they think they are the
forces of good stopping evil
from destroying the planet you know it's
not just that you don't believe in
climate change you're killing the planet
i'm not convinced of that i'm i'm not
convinced they actually want to
i don't think they have a moralistic
goal they just want power for the sake
of power
they want to be able to tell you to shut
up and do as you're told because we're
the boss now
i've seen it i've been on the ground
with these activists you you you can see
it and
and you brought up something about you
know the statist versus the libertarian
i think that really is a good point
because you take a look at the
conservative never trumpers or if you
you can call them even if you can call
them conservative i don't even know
they're democrats now yeah they're on
board jennifer rubin for the washington
post
she's now attacking the media for asking
biden questions
she's gone full authoritarian status and
that's opportunist
you know they're opportunists who
followed the money and they followed the
status quo that allowed them to keep
their
influence and you know they didn't care
their principles mattered less
than their access to power and i think
it's exactly the correct answer
principles lack thereof yeah they didn't
have anything to begin with
and we learned that i think the good and
evil thing is so dangerous it's so
subjective how you're raised what you
think is right and what you think is
wrong and and
to to establish public policy based on
what you
feel is so dangerous like i think biden
thinks he's doing good in protecting
people by doing this
how would you define evil ian exactly um
ripping someone's heart out and and how
about lifting it up in front of a crowd
of people but
600 years ago in in mexico and the aztec
culture that was no problem
that was good why
innocent is someone who has done no harm
to someone else
you know if you've got some if you want
to get the simple
okay but it's not very nuanced you know
if you've got a thing where you say
i am going to actively be violent
against someone else
based on my beliefs then you're evil
if you if you believe if a person says
to your face
ian concentration camps are here and and
they're right there in florida
and then come out and tell you okay so
first let me ask you ian do you think
concentration camps are evil
that's a that's a big question i don't
think it i don't think it's a hard
question because i don't think you'll
find a single human
a single human who's going to agree when
china
denies what's going on with the uyghur
muslims they actively go no that's not
happening here they're lying it's not
true you know why
if they thought it was good they'd say
we absolutely do this
but they know it's wrong so they lie
about it because everyone thinks well
like
world war ii they established
concentration camps for japanese
americans that's right they were afraid
a concentration camp implies that you're
killing people interesting so an
internment camp would be terminal campus
that's a that's a different form of a
prison camp it was wrong
and it's a different kind and it was
actually evil i believe
yeah for the sake of this argument let's
just say okay fine
we absolutely did that was wrong we we
paid reparations for it and even
people look back and they conservatives
look back and they say that was evil
that was wrong
and and even liberals look back and say
that was evil that was wrong
so yes many people many cultures have
done evil things
and then later on as we improve we say
that was evil
that you know so when i when i when i
look at evil i look at someone telling
you
that concentration camps are evil and
then a year later once they've attained
power
they say ours are justified when
aoc was screaming that donald trump's
power was illegitimate
and we were like oh okay it turns out
all she really cared about was she
wanted her party to have it
and once the democrats came in once they
won into
not joe biden's president they're just
influx facilities
and you know what aoc said one solution
would be to get them appropriate
licenses
so you mean to tell me that this was
evil
but now you entirely support it now that
your guy's in charge are they gonna
outsource and have now private prisons
for the immigrant children well they
want to shut down the actual private
prisons
but we'll open new private prisons
because we have to have a nice place
for our influx of children so so this is
the easiest one you know why
aoc herself referred to it as evil now
she's supporting it
well she she would be supporting it with
some caveats
okay if you tell me it's evil then you
come out and say can we get some
approval from the government for these
things we just need a license
i'm like oh okay so you enjoy being evil
that's evil yeah you know justifying it
something legally doesn't necessarily
make it good you know
bombing a city because those people are
planning to destroy your country
that's self-defense all right now let's
that's differentiate you wow that's
still
evil right then when you get into
self-defense all right how far forward
can you go right
i think that person's gonna hurt me so i
shot him in the head well
okay you have to have a legitimate
threat that you can stand up but then
you're responsible for the consequences
of your actions
and you can be judged even if you think
your intentions are good
you can be judged based on the outcome
of what you did and you should be
and we hold people accountable that's
why we can now say internment camps
for japanese and world war ii were evil
that was an evil thing the united states
did
slavery evil thing the united states did
not letting women vote
evil thing the united states did what's
the one thing about all those
we said they were wrong we changed them
and
now we can look back and say we're
making progress towards being
less evil every day and that's the goal
you can't you never get to good good's
way too subjective
but evil i think is easy and all you
need do is look at their own words
when they say this is wrong we must
fight it and we go okay we agree
let's get you into office so that you
can fight it and then go now we'll keep
it actually i got a good question for
you ian
was uh is zeal door was he wrong
zildor yeah the one ring yeah when
elrond said
destroy it cast it into the fire and he
went
no his soul was corrupted by the power
interrupted by the power
would you call that evil not to him it
doesn't matter what he thinks
we all watch objective it's about where
you are no listen i got to watch it from
the outside
that's right and everyone on middle
earth knew and al ron said it could have
ended that day and it should have
but as soon as he had the ring in his
hand he says
no way and he walked out of mount doom
and he kept that ring
and then it made everything worse and
that's exactly what i'm talking about
when libertarian individuals libertarian
right or libertarian left
look at the one ring i'm using there's a
metaphor mind you and we say
destroy it no one should have that power
we mean it but along comes
aoc aka gollum going me onset
and then when she takes the ring she
goes
and then she runs out and she keeps it
the only reason i can't go 100
with you on that is the ring as he said
did corrupt
their soul so that was not literally
a determination like aoc did it of free
will all right isildur did not have free
will because of the influence of the
ring
aoc's got no ring to blame she's just
got wokeness to blame
when boromir tried to take the ring from
frodo
aragorn kneeled before frodo and closed
his hand
he made the choice the ring could
corrupt you but some people had the
power to resist
and galadriel also resisted it yes
that's right but she was you know
and that's strength of character so
there you've got strong people and weak
people just as you do now
and so you've got people who like power
like aoc
more than they like being good the the
lord of the rings really is a great
metaphor the ring of power
i i do use it a lot because it you it's
it's it's brilliant writing it's a
brilliant metaphor or or you know
allegory for how these
political systems work everyone fights
because the power is evil
but the moment they're holding it and
they realize i could do
so much with this it's like in in the
fellowship of the ring when warmer is
like it is a gift
let us use the weapon against our
enemies you can't wield it no one can
and that's exactly what ends up
happening you get people like aoc
who says this stuff about concentration
camps you get these other democrats who
are like now that i'm in power i'll do
it right
so you know what happens this is why
communism doesn't work
one of the reasons just one it's because
these idealistic revolutionaries
think the ends justify the means we must
use violence they say
because we have to overthrow the evil
oppressors then once they're in power
they still say but we're at threat from
the evil oppressors
a good example the berlin wall was
called the anti-fascist protection
rampart
the soviet union one of the second most
powerful militaristic block on the
planet
was acting like they were at threat from
the fascists so they built the berlin
wall
and they killed people who dared cross
it that's evil
we can see that you know there are real
challenges to being a good person
that's why i always talk about how the
libertarian spectrum is harder to be on
the authoritarian and the libertarian
left is damn near impossible for those
that are libertarian left
true libertarian left because
libertarian leftists are trying to
convince people through goodwill
at least the the libertarian right has
money and they can talk about trade and
persuasion
but it's very difficult because the
authoritarians will lie cheat and steal
and take everything you have
and so what happens now is as you
pointed out eagles don't flock
good people of good conscience who say i
want you to be free i want you to be
happy and pursue happiness
and not be constrained by
authoritarianism and those who would
manipulate you to steal from you
well the other people don't do that the
the establishment doesn't do that
they're the ones saying the world is
going to end unless we intervene and
tell them what to do and we take over
and that's what and it works and their
intentions are good their intentions are
good but they understand human nature
doesn't allow people to do what they
want so in order to get them to do what
they want
the the new wokeness which is the brand
since socialism is busted and
communism's busted
liberalism is busted progressivism's
busted so wokeness
says we must do this because the people
who oppose it
are killing the planet you know it's not
just that you don't want black people to
succeed
you want to destroy the black community
you're actually a threat it's not just
that your speech
is something i don't want to hear it's
violence that's hurting people
so we have to shut you up that's what
they want it sounds like the communist
chinese party is woke
like that's their that's where it came
from they're no longer commenting our
people are communists that's what it
actually is
is our people stole marx and the soviet
union
and the stasi and the ccp's plans
and they built wokeness out of that they
just got better marketing
that's all they got they got american
style pr
that's the only difference they are
communist total
weapon i love the projection of it all i
love the projection of it all you know
they they
if anyone in this country has any
similarities to the nazi party it's the
identitarian left
you can actually you can actually look
at the things they preach they're pro
segregation
i saw this on reddit today it was in it
was i think it was in wholesome memes is
one of the subreddits where the memes
are you know you know
you know wholesome and it was martin
luther king jr looking angry
and it said judging people on the color
of their skin then it showed them
smiling and it said judging people on
the content of their character all the
comments were like
could you imagine someone who disagreed
with this and i was like wow have you
taken a look at the us military have you
taken a look at the pentagon have you
taken a look at schools
lately the new york city schools want to
do a i'm sorry
sacramento district want to do racial
affinity groups where they segregate
everybody based on race
sorry that these people don't support dr
king's dream
their idea their ideology is fascistic i
wouldn't call it fascism because not the
same thing
it's authoritarianism and it adopted
many of the tenets of fat from fascism
and david graber
who was a very famous activist
anthropologist he was an anarchist he
didn't like being called that apparently
but he pointed this out on twitter a few
years ago the late david graber
you know he was one of the voices behind
occupy wall street
and he tweeted a few years ago that
elements of the left have begun adopting
fascistic strategies and tactics
they believe there is no truth but power
that's exactly it
this is why the narrative changes and
there's no rules to these people
in the establishment and the woke left
there there is no truth but power
that means they will lie to you and tell
you insane things it's exactly why we
saw we saw so many prominent black lives
matter activists
smeared like insulting and you know
saying slurs against asian people for
years
now that the anti-asian hate thing has
become a big movement
now they're now all of a sudden they
flip-flopped but now they're getting
cancelled for it
the rules don't matter projection that's
the best thing about the left is
whenever you see them saying something
about the right
it's projection of what they feel inside
so they literally do have
racist tendencies they do have you know
tendencies against uh
asians they have fascistic tendencies
and they call us
nazis me being a person of the right
they call us nazis
because they want that kind of power i
don't want that kind of power
you know i'm not saying i know better
than you how you should live your life
i'm saying you should have the right to
live your life as long as you're not
harming other people
they say you are harming the planet and
all of its inhabitants
with your ideas and beliefs
i must stop you from doing it therefore
i need the power as you said but a lot
of these people know
that the average person views what
they're doing is wrong so they have to
lie about it
that's why i mentioned this meme where
you know dr king is saying
judge people based on the content of
their character because most people
agree with that
in order to instill racist nazi-like
ideology
they have to use clever semantic games
like anti-racist
are you anti-racist it's not enough to
not be racist you must be anti-racist
and then you ask him what anti-racism
means and you know what eber max candy
says
it means you must discriminate against
people on the basis of race i'm pretty
sure dr king
said not to do that oh but they don't
care they don't actually believe him
this is the one thing that really gets
these people whenever i'm talking to a
woke person i'll ask them the first
thing i will ask him is do you believe
in dr king's dream
i've actually now started hearing him
say no it's in it's in my other book the
myth of white fragility
taking down robin d'angelo's disgraceful
book she says in there that dr king's
dream of color blindness is a problem so
does candy
you know they say that you can't have a
colorblind society because
there is so much systemic racism and
institutional injustice that you have to
actively be an anti-racist
and be racist so it's essentially
building a new jim crow
all right they want a new jim crow and
it's not about voting laws
it's about who gets to be the upper side
now so they want to flip things because
white people were bad before
we need to now elevate black people and
people of color and go ahead and make
that the actual
legitimate power balance i don't think
they actually care about white people
i think they just want power and they've
found a path to get it and it doesn't
matter which race they trample on
that's why they ragged on asians for so
long interesting well
we're a good target you know because we
were oppressors you know they've got
that they can't take that away there was
oppression there was slavery there was
women couldn't vote all those things are
true
bald white guys and bad wigs wrote a
bunch of crazy stuff
right but we also fixed it right and we
gave those powers up
you look at how they actually claimed
asians were more privileged for a long
time
and that's why i think the issue where
they go after whiteness
is that it's an easy way to go to
someone and say all of your problems
come from someone else right it's
demagoguery
they accused trump of doing the exact
same thing when trump did to a certain
degree but not nearly as much as they do
when they say whiteness over and over
again and privilege and all that stuff
they're basically just telling people
the reason you failed is not your fault
it's that guy over there it's it's
brilliant i saw this great meme from a
leftist on facebook
it was it said it's one of those twitter
memes where it says uh employees
colon we need better wages and and uh
healthcare
healthcare because we're suffering and
dying and then it says
capital colon no and then it says woke
capital
no hashtag blm rainbow flag heart
and i'll i gotta i gotta say i love that
meme well i certainly don't agree with
their view on capitalism
at least they're starting to notice the
corporatist establishment is not going
to give the leftists what they want
they're just going to put a rainbow flag
up and say now you can't be mad at us
well and what i love most though is they
they needed an enemy
all right and like you said okay it's
not so much maybe they don't actually
believe the white people the problem i
think they do
but they made whiteness evil they turned
they turned it into an ideology that
doesn't exist whiteness didn't exist for
me
i've been white for a long time all
right i didn't have a methodology
towards my whiteness
i didn't wake up and say okay 9 to 9 30
i'm going to press black people
you know 9 45 i'll switch to trans
people no i was busy living my life
but they othered us they used their own
methodology and now
they've got someone to go against and
they've got something to they've got
spoils
because what they did is they take their
identity groups right and they create
a grievance and they take that grievance
to someone who has something they want
and they use their power they aggregate
power by delivering the spoils to their
identity group the problem is
they've run into the circular firing
squad problem they can't rectify among
their identity groups
the problems they have because you got
black people beating up asians
you know you got a lot of issues and
jews and you've got problems between
these groups
that are are not just cognitive
dissonance they're ideological
dissonance
and they can't rectify that you remember
what happened in the uk when the muslims
were protesting the
lgbt curriculums in schools right it was
really weird because
you'd have these woke people come out
and start arguing with muslims and you'd
have like women in like full niqab
and then you have a man screaming in the
face of a woke person who's confused
and there was one video where i was like
i'm here to help you i'm on your side
i'm here to help you i'm like no you're
not
the the muslim guy's like this is
degeneracy and you're wrong and i'm like
i wonder if these people who truly
believe their insane
psychobabble have ever actually spoken
with a religious conservative person
and i don't mean a christian i mean when
they come out they they
you know i had a friend who has that a
picture of a woman in a hijab and it
says something like hope or something
like
hope underneath it and i'm like it's
really fascinating that
you are propping up religious
conservatism and like because islam is
substantially more traditional than even
modern christianity
totalitarian if it's implemented the way
you know the
the salafists and that's the fun part
there's this perfect circular firing
squad right there is you've got people
who hate gays and want to hang them from
cranes
arguing with a gay dude who's telling
them that they're oppressed
and arguing about a curriculum that they
don't want in their school
there's no way you could square that
circle and that's that's how we beat
them though
but that's how we beat them the issue is
i don't think i think the circular
firing squad matters to a certain degree
you right now we've got this like school
board
member in in california they're
demanding she resigned because she said
a bunch of disparaging things about
asian people
but at the time they were allowed to do
that it was part of their ideology to
disparage asians
now that they can't do that they're
coming for you know circular following
squad firing squad but this person said
i'm not going i don't care
and how long until they just move on to
the next stupid nonsense and start
claiming that
you know who knows the next thing's
going to be just some some ridiculous
form of oppression that a minority group
will have
it's like oh you know people with with
long fingernails that you know they just
grow too long so
they're oppressed people who eat too
much they're oppressed we know that
here's where i think it might bite them
is they they invented this several
generations of
entitled grievance mongers i call them
right who
have been told that they're it's not
your fault it's those people's fault
now they work at places like google
you're familiar with timnit gaburu
no she was the head of google's
artificial intelligence ethics
team oh yeah she's a black woman she
built a team
of the purple haired freakazoid robots
and all her best friends right
they wanted to publish a paper the
problem was it went through google's
review board and they said first of all
the science is kind of garbage
second of all you're trashing our
company and third of all this is
basically just woke
grievances right fix it or we're not
going to let you put it out under our
name
and they launched it and then google
fired her yeah right and all of a sudden
it's not because she violated both
scientific principles academic
principles and
company policy it's because she's black
and now she's got
thousands of google employees who are
backing her play
because she's been told you're not wrong
you're just being oppressed right if
you're black at google
then and you don't get everything you
want you have a right to demand
that they they meet your your grievances
james damore
was an excellent example of how insane
the ideology is
so uh you're familiar with james the
more imagine ian are you yeah so for
those that aren't familiar he wrote a
letter about ways to improve the
workplace between men and women
and it was based on scientific research
and he was like sharing with people and
then a bunch of feminists got really
offended by it
and then he ended up losing his job
there was a lawsuit i think they settled
the funny thing is james damore's
document was actually
based upon modern feminist theory it
said things like
workplaces were designed by men for men
and that we need to change things to
better suit women
according to a study women prefer social
social experiments
experiences more so than like top-down
and isolated
work environments if men prefer x and
women prefer y
the workplace must be some combination
of the two to accommodate for women
the women said how dare you imply women
are inherently one way or another
we are angry you should be fired to
reiterate how insane that is
he was literally saying that google's
work environment was built by patriarchy
and that he needed they needed to
accommodate the fema the the woman
better and so they got mad and demanded
he lose his job
the women did isn't that amazing he's
he's basically agreeing with everything
they've been saying
you can't accommodate them that's the
thing you can't accommodate them and
what they figured out is all they need
is a disparity of outcome
all right you say we have a disparity
there are too few black
engineers you know with freckles working
at google
therefore they're that's a racist
systemic
issue that they have to deal with and
then they jump right from there instead
of looking at outcomes and say well
maybe there aren't a lot of black
freckled people
who get into the tech field maybe that's
why there aren't as many at google
they're like no no it's racism right so
they skip the step
of the scientific process it says you
identify a disparate outcome
and then you look at potential causes
identify the ones that correlate the
best
they jump straight from that to systemic
racism but the problem is
that eliminates any look at root causes
and you can never fix it
so that's where equity comes in so one
really great example of the corruption
colleges
not majority female okay many many
colleges i should say are majority
female so okay so
so men are now the minority in colleges
do we now start abolishing all of the
women's programs women's scholarships
no and creating men's ones i don't think
so so you think the majority should get
privileged money and access and
resources what are you a bigot
shouldn't the minorities be the one who
get help because they're in the minority
well that would be like dudes in college
at this point because it's mostly women
and here's the thing that changed in my
lifetime when i was in elementary school
that was when they started that stuff
and they said there aren't enough women
going to college there aren't enough so
they literally
inside of several decades managed to
flip that on its head
now the question is what do we want do
we want equality of outcome
right we want to make sure that every
group in society
is equally represented in every outcome
that we can come up with because that's
what wokeness demands
and it can't be met because humans
humans don't work that way
so what we have to figure out is how do
we get back to equality of opportunity
because that's all you can do and that's
that's where i think our side needs to
look at it and say
we can see the disparate outcome i agree
with you there's too many black people
in prison i don't want them in prison
except most of them committed crimes so
how do we stop
committing crimes now how do we get them
out of prison well there's there's
interesting arguments about that
uh questions about whether or not based
on race they'll get harsher sentences
for the same crime
which there are stats that show and so
the issue i see
there's real instances of racism there's
real instances of bias
uh historical racism has created a
ripple effect throughout history
in today's modern generation and an
honest person like i think you'd hear
this from tucker carlson
of course there's racism we'd like to
solve these problems
but these people are hustlers they're
grifters they're manipulators
they they tell the privileged elites
they're oppressed they would claim to
you
that oprah winfrey or serena williams
are oppressed meanwhile a homeless
veteran sleeping under a gutter who
happens to be white is the oppressor
that's the insanity of their ideology
honest people say
yeah you know racism is a problem i
think we've actually done a lot in this
country to do away with it
we've passed many new laws there's been
new supreme court rulings we've done a
tremendous job
ending these things but there are
remnants of these historical policies
and actions
in private and public affairs redlining
and blockbusting
very serious consequences for for uh for
various people
well the the the people on the left
manipulate
the goodwill of regular people who don't
want racism
and they lie to them and tell them they
can't advance exactly we've done a lot
of legal good
uh to combat racism in the united states
emotional
is like an up and down back and forth
situation and when we let the media
tell us that we're different because of
the colors of our skins
that kind of is damaging or undoing a
lot of the good we can do to unify
humans in our culture but i do agree
that legally the united states has done
a lot of
positive things to bypass and break
through the racist curtain
and wokeness is re-segregating that's
the problem
identity politics is re-segregation and
they're they're breaking people out and
saying no your skin color actually is
more important
than the content of your character and
so we're going to put you in this block
and you will vote with these people and
you will identify with these people
and you will get spoils from us because
you're one of these people and that's
the most destructive thing
to what is a a republic of equals
i can even imagine is to say that no the
intangible characteristics
matter more than your character that
that offends me more than anything else
they do
and i think we can call out races we can
call out these problems
and say we want to fix them and we want
to help but we have to do it by saying
yes the content of your character
matters more in the color of your skin
let's talk about where this leads to as
not only the result of this ideology but
one of the tactics in the ideology and
we got the story from newsweek which i
find absolutely
sad it's sad and funny police prepare
for another hot summer of violent street
clashes as
us reopens really nothing's even
happened yet
what what what covid is going to cause
this what the getting people getting
back from covet is going to cause riots
i don't think that's pretty no i think
what they're saying
is that regardless the police are
getting prepared
because even though there's been no
police brutality even though there's
been no major breaking story the cops
know
that doesn't matter you'll get a video
of a you know
i'll tell you i'll give you an example
there's a cop playing basketball with
the local kids and they're all laughing
one of the kids happens to be black and
the cop
he he he's you know he's going up to you
know do a jump shot he jump shots
and then he bumps into one of the kids
the kid falls over and then everyone
shows a clip of a cop bumping into a kid
and knocking him over and they're like
please brutality
i'm exaggerating obviously but the point
i'm making is you'll get something out
of context
you'll get some hip-hop some some
hearsay some
random rumor and then all of a sudden
here we go again you know what else that
article is saying is our company
newsweek is
flailing and losing money and we're
desperate for clicks so here's some rage
bait
crap well here's the funny thing though
the cops are getting ready i'll tell you
what the cops are getting ready to do
they're loading their stuff to get out
of the way for the riots because their
civilian leaders are not going to let
them stop those riots
and like you said it they got a the most
recent incident cop shoots a kid
who had a gun doesn't matter that the
kid had a gun you know he was 15
he had a gun he got shot the cops are
supposed to shoot that kid
when he points a gun at him let's talk
they're not supposed to take a bullet
let's talk about those two girls in dc
who carjacked that guy
right yeah carjacked him committing a
felony killed him
they're not going to get jail time no
kyle rittenhouse
defending a local business chased and
attacked by a violent rioter of
violent rioters fires in self-defense
and immediately runs to get police
assistance
he's in jail dude those girls carjacked
that guy and then
hit the gas and murdered him threw him
out of his car and murdered him
no jail time at one level 13 and 15
i'm like they're not adults you know i
i'm i'm
having 17 elevate that but it also sends
a message that i'll keep carjacking
now written house will get off i i have
looked at that i'm actually writing a
piece
that i'm going to give to the defense
justifying
why that is self-defense by every
legitimate legal standard
but why did he get charged with
first-degree murder i'll tell you why
because black lives matter intimidated
the civilian leaders
through violence into changing their
policy and charging with that now what's
that
that's domestic terrorism it is we
haven't we have no real leaders
no one is immune to uh belligerence like
i mean i just keep thinking of nazi
germany man they thought they were dem
they were democracy up until that point
the german people and
if violent coercion can happen at any
time to any group of people
so we have to be we have to be aware of
that we have to be cognizant that that
can take hold man and that's there's no
leaders bro
they're they're fine i know
where was the prosecutor from wisconsin
to walk out and say
i'm not charging him with a crime have a
nice day
in the same place in in minneapolis were
or anyplace else
because but here's the dangerous thing
black lives matter has now been told
that violence to intimidate public
policy works
so they committed terrorist acts those
were used to change policy
and now they were rewarded with hundreds
of millions of dollars in revenue
and the policies they want so we're in a
situation where there are now two rules
all right we had an afternoon of
violence at the capitol and that was the
greatest insurrection and biggest threat
to the republic in the history of earth
and we had an entire year plus of
insurrection by the left
and it's like meh you know because
excuse me excuse me excuse me no no no
those were peaceful protests
mostly mostly fiery but peaceful 93
one of the best ever and no fiery but
mostly peaceful protest
but the threat of violence doesn't even
have to be violence now now here's where
they won
they committed the violence and they
will again because hey i mean somebody
needs flat screen
you know we got it flat screens are in
high demand
but whatever justification they use to
start the riots
those will happen the police will not
stop them again
and again people now kyle rittenhouse
was literally
acting as a member of the militia not
the militia by name
that kenosha guard or whatever it was
but the in the second amendment
it is expected that in the absence of
government authority to keep people safe
they have the right and the ability to
protect themselves
themselves and their property so he went
and protected property at the invitation
of the owners
and with with a with and he did not
bring a gun across state lines no
his friend gave him a gun okay and the
issues about should he have had the gun
he's 17 okay those are legitimate
deal with those but that's
administrative right the right of people
in the absence of the police the police
were stood down and pulled back and
people's businesses and livelihoods and
lives were threatened they have a right
to have weapons and to protect
themselves
that's what the militia is here's
another question does the second
amendment say
the uh a well-regulated militia be
necessary for you know
free free free estate the right to keep
and bear arms shall not be infringed
comma
unless of course you are under the age
of 18
you have a mental illness you are a
felon it doesn't actually say any of
those things no
now i understand there's interpretations
in you know from the supreme court
but i wonder which of those would
actually stand in the long run because
you know back then what a 15 year old
was an adult yeah
they could have guns and i think biden
as much as he
is a doddering fool and an idiot and
said some dumb things today of course no
amendment is absolute
all right there there are no actual
absolutes in politics it's not possible
to have an absolute in politics
but what you can say is under the
interpretations and the standing law and
precedent
right now the things he's doing are
unconstitutional
as per heller versus dc or dc versus
heller you know i would do if i was in
congress
i would create the two plus two equals
four bill and it would simply say
congress asserts that two plus two
equals four that's it
you're gonna vote on it or not because
they tried saying the woke people two
plus two could equal five
i would i would probably filibuster that
because in base three math there is no
numeral four you only have zero one two
matter it's always the geek
it's always they got you i'm the number
but this is this is exactly the the
constructivist ideology that i can
change the definition in order to make
you wrong
as opposed to admitting what we know is
two plus two equals four
you can change the context but now
you're arguing something totally
different
it would be like if we were playing
baseball and i said
if i hit this ball a hundred feet and it
goes over that fence
it's a home run you go well some fences
are at 75 feet
some are at 150 feet i'm like i didn't
ask that i'm talking about this
fence right here so what they're doing
is they're going well two plus two
could equal five cause what if we're
saying two point four plus two point
four which is four point eight which
rounded up is five
well you didn't say two two point four
did you base so so the point is you said
in base ten
base 5 or above 2 plus 2 equals 4 i
cannot deny that
what average person is thinking in
anything other than base 10 right now
probably none of them
none of them so this is the
constructivist ideology
to change the definition to manipulate
the results
look at the best one they did all right
they changed the definition of racism
right so that you have to be in a
position of power
in order to be a racist so that black
people and other people of color and
and other identity groups that are our
preferred victim groups
cannot be racist that's garbage you know
once you do that it's the same as saying
okay now
men women male female okay those words
male female still i think are xxy
right anymore but i changed it did they
so
man woman means nothing regular people
in this country
will say male and female are specific
they
they relate specifically to the gametes
you know sperm or egg
in woke nomenclature male and female are
arbitrary concepts that don't mean
anything right and they say by
they've said this for years now in a
debate with jordan peterson there was
one
uh university employee historian of
medicine who said
that biological sex is not a real thing
which is just absolutely untrue
they're doing these things that's why i
was like right now you have an
opportunity to pass a bill that says two
plus two equals four
you'll probably get some opposition no
joke okay you will
but that's a good so we can excuse me we
can
stand up and say okay that's bs you know
and that's the problem is for too long
they've been unopposed and they've been
doing that they've been changing
definitions and people were like i'm
busy i got to get my kids to soccer
practice right
well you can no longer get your kids to
soccer practice in this country
if they're going to do what they're
doing you have to spend some of your
time
fighting back against wokeness or we
will no longer have a republic
where your kids are allowed to play
soccer the racist thing i can't i can't
wrap my head around it's like some
debates i can have two plus two equals
four okay
there's multiple bases of mathematics
four doesn't exist in all of them
the racist thing to say that just
because a class or or a group of people
are are prejudiced against that it's
impossible for them to be racist against
other other types is in that i can't i
can't come to terms with
but that's what they want and that's i
mean it's all 1984. all right orwell did
this
you know back long ago the idea is to
tell you
what truth is and confuse you so you
can't oppose it
because they want power and you get
power by forcing people to accept
your version of the truth that's why
they say let me give you my truth
right no and rest in power yeah no there
is no
your truth you have your opinion right
it's not your truth
there is truth there is falsehood there
is good there is evil
there are absolutes in philosophical
ideas like that
there are not absolutes in politics and
what they want to do is flip that on its
head
and give you their absolutes in politics
which is that
black people can't be racist and expect
you not to
go no flag on the play you're sorry
have you seen the winnie the pooh meme
where it's like a regular winnie the
pooh
then it says a word then it's him
wearing a monocle then him wearing a
suit
there's one where it's regular winnie
the pooh and it says my opinion then
it's him with a monocle and like a
mustache and it says
anecdotal evidence and then the bottom
one is him in a tuxedo and it says my
lived experience
[Laughter]
but okay there you are you know as long
as you can say it is
how i feel because it's all about the
feels you know the left lives on emotion
all right and and wokeness is all about
you trying to create a society where
people can't be
judged as good bad or indifferent and
they can't be
offended they have a right to be free
from offense
which conflicts with the first amendment
which was designed
so i can offend you i'm sorry it
conflicts with reality
like i i get offended by the woodpecker
who keeps banging on the tree outside
what am i going to do about it sometimes
things exist
i get offended by the rain how dare you
rain i'm trying to skateboard right here
what are you some things you can't do
anything about well you can get a bb gun
and take care of that woodpecker
unless it's a red-cockaded woodpecker in
which case you can't because right
yeah well the idea is you could be
sitting in your own home
sitting there with your gut hanging out
drinking a beer and eating your
fifth slice of pizza and amy schumer
comes on and you go
go she's nasty and then they they
they find out and they freak out and
they get mad how dare you say that
you you're fat phobic also like if two
people are hanging out and one person
feels offense who who did the offending
was it was this person offended or did
this person offend
or or did did this person receive it or
or crea you can't we gotta like it's
just how i feel about you
yeah yeah yeah i can't say it's good i
feel this so you made me feel it it's no
no no i made myself feel this way
based on my surroundings that i the way
i perceive it teaches that you should
look for a fence i mean they literally
teach that's why the grievance is so
important the grievance is the basis
for wokeness because you need the
grievance to create a need for spoils
and reparations so are they is this this
like
proactive defense thing like i think
they're going to harm me in the future
so i'm going to i'm going to come out
hard and strong and no no
no no bomb the country i want power so
i'm going to manipulate people
to get power it's that simple right now
a lot a lot of people
you ever see fight club yeah he's just
watching clips from them
remember that line from edward norton
where he's like a lot most people will
do everything in their power to avoid
getting into a fight
yeah the woke people figured that out so
they go into your workplace
and you're sitting there typing away on
your computer like i want to get my job
done and they go
excuse me dude that's terror did you
have a turkey sandwich
turkey is racist because the pilgrims
used turkey as a symbol of their colony
colonization when they killed the native
americans
you can't be eating turkey today because
it's indigenous day
and then you know people do i'm so sorry
i had no idea i'm so sorry
i don't want to get into a fight i don't
want to i don't want to deal with this
can i just go home now
it's like low-key terrorism it's
literally without a doubt it's
information warfare against you
and the only answer to it is to not care
right i mean that's that's my favorite
thing when i wrote myth of white
fragility i'm like
i wonder if i'm going to get called a
racist
and after the 65 000th time
it didn't bother me to start with right
because i know i'm not
but the idea now that everyone needs to
be able to stand up and say no you can
call me that
but it doesn't change my lived reality
right which is that i'm not and so i'm
going to stand up and say shut up
it could be in a jerk you know i got
work to do first of all get out of here
and second of all i'm having another
turkey it's amazing to me how many
people try to convince these woke people
that they're not actually racist i'm
like bro they know you're not racist
they don't care
like i tweeted something on this phone
on twitter right so i had this big rant
on a couple different nights about
campaign finance and how i really really
think it's wrong that billionaires can
dump hundreds of millions of dollars
to for instance ban gun rights i i say
that one because it should resonate with
people who want second amendment
when you get tom steyer and bloomberg
spending you know 500 million bucks
to convince people guns to be banned by
lying about what an assault weapon is
even though that doesn't really define
anything that makes me angry the same is
true for any billion i don't care what
they're pushing i don't like the idea
that someone's going to spend money
going into your district and then tell
all your neighbors to vote against their
own rights i got a problem with that
so we get this thing where uh marjorie
taylor green she raises 3.2 million
dollars in her first quarter
aoc only raised 768k so marjory taylor
green has raised nearly five times as
much
as aoc did in her first quarter and so i
quote tweeted and i just put
i'm laughing you know i'm laughing
because
they like to talk about the millionaires
and the billionaires and i've been
complaining about external
donations into districts to manipulate
politics
i was laughing about marjorie taylor
greene because it shows the media's
smears backfired
and campaign finance which they don't
care about aoc
is now propping up some they don't like
but these people don't
so what happens is they tweet at me like
see you clearly support marjorie taylor
green i'm like
i'm not going to argue with you because
you're an idiot i know you're you have
no idea what you're talking about
it's just tribalism where they pretend
they pretend where they're like
are you actually going to defend
marjorie taylor green and i was like
what about hahahahaha is it defending
anybody
like please explain that to me the best
part about that was where you showed the
part where google translated it
to god yeah yeah yeah the translation
was your ai needs some work yeah
yeah it wasn't even a translation that
was the best yeah so google offered to
translate it for me and i
you're saying don't bother defending
yourself against it i think that's a
great
statement because i mean if an alligator
wants to fight you underwater it's going
to drag you into water
you're going to lose that fight exactly
you got to make them go on land
so one thing i always look out for when
people actually try and debate you
a common tactic of dim-witted or
mid-wooded individuals
is to force you to fight underwater it's
a good good analogy ian
and so what will happen is they'll it's
martin bailey they'll say i think x and
you'll go
while x is this and they'll go well
actually but why no we're not talking
about why i don't care
never let them redirect someone will
like uh so there's a guy i know who like
tweets at me
and he quote tweets me and he'll say
something like tim poole did x i'll
respond with actually i did y
and then he'll change the subject change
the subject and be like yeah well don't
you remember when you did z and i'll be
like
when it comes to y i just totally
disregard any attempt at derailing and
dragging me underwater
i won't even mention it they want to
derail you
and there's literally no reason to talk
about something you don't want to talk
about so don't fight don't find an
alligator underwater if someone says
that's a quote from ian
do you think a or b you don't have to
say
a or b you can say whatever you your
answer can be anything you do not have
to answer questions the way people want
you
like ian what color is the sky it
doesn't matter
[Laughter]
so we do we've got free will we can
literally do
what we want we don't have to do what
they say that's true that's a great way
to fight what
people are scared i know and that's the
problem all right and they should be
scared
because they're very good at hurting you
all right they're attacking your
livelihood
you know they'll attack you at your
family they'll attack you at your work
they can get you fired all right that
hurts regular people in a real way
that's why we have to band together now
we don't have to form you know support
groups
and have safe spaces for people on the
right to say oh the wokeness is is
making me feel bad
we just have to do what you did is tell
them i'm not going to play your game
i don't even say it you didn't care
don't even acknowledge the game
i think at some level you have to with
this but you can do
you can stop them from the redirect you
can say no no i'm just talking about
what you just did
you said i'm a racist for eating turkey
that's garbage
and if you want to go anywhere from
there i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
indulge you
but i don't believe eating turkey is
racist neither do you
you're a jerk for bringing it up you
want you wanna know what i would do i'd
show up the next day with turkey
sandwiches for the entire office
yes we we had we had vosh on the show do
you know what washes
and i had some you know right
personalities say like i can't believe
you would invite this person on your
show
and so my response is i'm gonna book
them again it's like dude i don't play
that game
you're not scared of a different opinion
you're not scared of people who disagree
with you you don't feel they have to be
isolated and pushed out and and
quarantined
i i think if we we we need to talk to
people
did you get a that backstage man how did
you get that i'm stuck
how could you have people with different
opinions on your show i lived in madison
wisconsin all right which is
one of the reddest cities on earth i was
introduced by everyone who knew me there
as this is jim my conservative friend
because i was the only one
they knew right yet we managed to
co-exist
all right we managed to disagree we
managed to say that hey
okay you have because what i do with
them is i say look i think we have the
same goal
i think we both want people to be safe
and prosperous and live their lives and
not
be killed by things all right but i
think we have different
methods that we think will achieve that
and i think mine are more effective and
here's why i think yours
are less effective and if in the end we
don't agree
we go our separate ways we vote and we
continue to live as americans
the problem with woke-ism is you can't
do that
because they think if you don't follow
their way you are
actually literally causing harm and they
they have
actually a religious duty to them to
stop you
we do have good news though there is a
phrase i'm sure most of you have uh have
heard
get woke go broke oh yeah check this
story out from bounding in the comics
new rumor claims that falcon and the
winter soldier viewers turned off the
show after black lives matter messaging
um before we even get in this i'm just
going to say i believe it
so there was there was there was this
meme uh i would say it was
some data that was posted on reddit
where it was like critic reviews versus
audience review disparities
so it was like a data reddit and you can
see where
movies where the critics said it was bad
but the audience said it was good
and movies where the critics said it was
good and the audience said was bad
captain marvel was one of them
captain marvel is rotten according to
the audience
but fresh according to the the critics
surprise surprise so here's the story
they say this if those aren't familiar
the the falcon in the winter soldier is
one of those new shows on disney plus
they say a relatively new rumor claims
that viewers of the recently released
falcon in the winter soldier
turned it off after the show featured
black lives matter messaging
they say overlord dvd claims that a
source communicated to him
that the tune out time stamp for the
second episode of
the falcon of the winter soldier
revealed viewers stopped watching the
show before the episode ended
as explained by overlord dvd tots is
logged at tots is uh
time stamp what is it tune out timestamp
is logged on disney plus whenever a
viewer stops watching a particular movie
or television episode
it's useful to the bean counters at
disney plus to note when they lose a
particular viewer
because this can give them valuable data
about how the show is doing and what the
viewer thinks about
it goes on a state the source claims
that around 5 p.m on saturday across the
board
the time out tune the the timeout tune
stamp is that wait
the tune out time stamp they got it
backwards for a second episode of the
falcon this winter soldier went crazy
with people turning off the show in
droves all around the same part of the
show within seconds
that part of the show apparently they
show this image
where the cops pull up to sam and bucky
now bucky's a white dude sam's a black
dude
and the cops are like is there a problem
sir to the to bucky who's white
and he's like no he's my friend they're
like are you all right what's he doing
and then he's like don't you know who
this is and they're like what that's the
falcon and they go
oh i'm so sorry i saw that and i was
just like dude
come on that's subtle though that was
really subtle
yeah i'm missing this who's the falcon
the falcon yeah
like not not the broads no i don't know
who the falcon is
but is the falcon the white guy or the
black guy okay yeah and they were like
have reverence for this guy and everyone
else the cops pulled up
and they saw a white guy and a black guy
arguing and then asked the white guy if
he was all right and if he needed help
because of this black guy
because he fit the profile yeah he was a
superhero
and then bucky is like don't you know
who that is it's like that's the falcon
and then the cop goes like oh
geez i didn't realize they were doing
this you know
yeah they're very kind of over the head
a little bit
that's the problem they can't keep it
out of the culture i mean breitbart said
the greatest thing
you know politics is downstream from
culture all right that's what they do is
they inject those things
into the culture and they expect people
not to notice here's the problem
they are so unsubtle these days trump
made them so crazy
that they ripped the masks off and they
stopped being subtle and now they're
just
beating you over the head about it wow
and people don't like that trump was the
artistic trojan horse
he got in there and just caused the
entertainment industry to go haywire or
the giant stink bomb
let off in the room or whatever you want
to call it but he made them so angry
they stopped being good
at their pr game check this out they're
going to say the source says quote
my jaw hit the floor i couldn't believe
what i was seeing all
the turnout was at the cop scene where
it clearly shows they were ready to pull
their guns on a black eye arguing with a
white guy it's clear
this was the message he goes on to state
so in other words disney felt like
sticking a black lives matter message
smack dab in the middle of falcon and
winter soldier episode 2
and what do you know apparently fans who
are sick to death of bad news and tragic
headlines
decided they had enough and turned the
episode off overlord dvd claims
according to his source over the course
of friday and saturday a full 79.9
of people that were tuning in stopped
watching at that point in the story
the number would apparently increase of
the next few days as well according to
this source for the next few days
the average went up to 83.49 overall
that means 83.49 of viewers turned off
the episode
at almost exactly the same woke point he
adds the source claims
there were also a lot of subsequent
cancellations happening in real time
maybe it's not a real source maybe it's
not good information i don't know it's
rumor
it's rumor it makes me feel good how
about that nothing else
and here's the nice thing we can play
information warfare yeah that's actually
definitive i heard a guy say that too
there is no disney guy is now in my ear
right now telling me that that's fact
that that like um that like uh what'd
you call it
enhances my love for humanity my belief
that humanity is
awake aware and wise if that's real the
get well go brook stuff yeah the people
just have no time for this junk i was
just watching family guy earlier
and it's one of the older episodes where
uh joe who's the cop you guys know
family guy
he pulls up and then you know peter's
sitting on the couch and he hears on a
megaphone it's the police you know come
out with your hands up or something
peter goes outside and he sees cleveland
quagmire and joe
in a swat van and he's like wow what's
this
and then joe's like come on we're going
for a beer run in this new police van
the next scene that shows them in the
police van and then joe goes
the van is equipped with the latest
police technology he says peter stand in
the circle peter walks into a circle and
then also an arms come down and goes
you are under arrest and then it grabs
his hands and cuffs him you have the
right to remain silent
and then peter goes wow cool and then
cleveland goes let me try cleveland of
course being the black character
and joe goes cleveland no wait don't and
then two arms come down with batons and
start beating him going
minority suspect found and then when
quagmire falls to the ground they go oh
no
he has a gun and then it lowers a gun
that was really funny it was it's an old
family guy joke
that's one way to incorporate these
ideas in humor
that most people would laugh about
because it's not asserting necessarily
as a truth it's not like a scene
in an action drama where the cops are
going after a superhero oh no because
they're racist
it was making a joke about racism while
being very very subtle and funny about
it um
and robert downey jr in tropic thunder
do you guys see that movie i was just
watching the interview with him and
rogan last night again and he was
talking about it and how it's still he
hasn't been
you know because that that movie was
making fun of the actors that would play
that character of blackface he wasn't
playing blackface he was playing a white
guy that was
in blackface and it was very obvious
that how how ridiculous
it it can be and that's what family guy
does in a lot of ways
and it's what crowder does a lot of ways
they cancel him for it they try to
cancel him for him but if they got back
to that like it's when jon stewart
started doing the news
and he became essentially cnn for the
left and when he was doing the daily
show
he would play clown nose on clown nose
off it was never off
right it was all clown nose yeah and
because of that he inserted so much
leftist propaganda
and viewpoints that he could never get
in and get people to listen to in a
straight news shot but jon stewart was
honest
he was jon stewart praised project
veritas on more than one occasion
they wouldn't do that today they
wouldn't because jon stewart recognized
he had his opinion well i'll put it this
way jon stewart was a guy who has his
opinions who were liberal
he had liberal opinions but he was an
honest guy about his opinions
that's why i thought the daily show was
awesome with him so when project veritas
did the whole acorn sting
he was like journalists where are you
this dude's pulling off major journalism
what's going on and he shows james
o'keefe in the pimp out and all that
stuff
and then later on he also praised him
you know in another in another
circumstance
imagine don lemon and brian stelter
being like
these conservative journalists are doing
a great job now never going to happen
they've gone past they've gone over the
top in their own beliefs and it's it's
partly
because now they're so angry they can't
see that it's not working
and it is working all right it's working
for a large segment of the population
who doesn't have the time
to break through the haze but now you've
got alternative sources of information
like what we're doing right here and
other places for now
for now but so what you're building
you're building subscription it's
brilliant
it's a brilliant idea to tell people hey
they're coming for all of us
and point out they're coming for you too
all right whoever you are out there
right now they're coming for you in some
way shape or form
get on board and fight back because
that's what we're doing and this is
important too because i'm
it's going to be a shout out for
timcast.com but it's also an important
point about what you can do and what
we're doing
so we set up timcast.com initially just
like okay we need a place to put content
in the event we get banned because
facebook actually put a restriction on
my my page and now that page is
basically defunct
so we start teamcast.com we're gonna do
bonus segments for everybody we got a
bunch of new members and i said okay
let's build an even better website let's
let's
streamline it update the upgrade the
graphics and make it look better
and then i was like we need to actually
make culture so i got a script i
got i'm sorry not a script i got a
treatment a proposal for a show sent to
me by a comedian
we want to make a sitcom i said let's do
it let's make a sitcom
maybe maybe we'll try and get it on a
mainstream streaming service or maybe
i'll just put on timecast.com because
i'll tell you
i want to create a website where we just
do comedy specials we do sitcoms we do
drama we do movies we do video games
we just start building the culture
that's been taken over by the woke
vice man yeah when i i remember why i
wanted to why i wanted to go to vice why
i talked to them and i said
i'd like to work here because they were
edgy
they were regular people they were crazy
yeah absolutely
but they'd they'd go you know look you
had ryan duffy's bulletproof clothing
he goes down to meet this crazy guy
who's like i make clothes that are
bulletproof and they actually shoot
he's wearing this trench coat super
heavy and thick and you know bulletproof
those were fun and exciting stories
where some regular guy who is off the
cuff kind of punk rock
sex drugs and rock and roll were going
on these adventures now it's
woke ultra woke it's as establishment as
it comes
it's boring mainstream corporate garbage
we need to bring back fun
exciting and you know we need to bring
back punk rock man
i think it's the brilliant i love when
we claim now that
conservatism is punk rock you know now
that it's being a lot of it is
being and but let's just make it
anti-war because everybody gets hung up
on things i don't want to be
conservative i'm not a republican you
know okay
neither am i but i am anti-woke
all right i'm based whatever you want to
call it well the left user is based as
well
yeah i'm shooting white pills whatever
whatever you want to characterize it as
we're punk rock we are now the rebels
we're the anti-establishment
so weird isn't it yeah i love it last
night we had brandon tatum on the show
um officer brantanum he's no longer
enough police officer
and we were talking about running away
from a fight and he was saying where he
grew up
you were thought of as a punk if you
would turn and run and he kept saying
punk and it crossed my mind a couple
times that like
yo punk rock it is punk to run away from
a fight
that's punk rock no no no that's not
what he was saying he was saying you
were getting punked
yeah he he's using the same word punk
and it's like that word synonymous
sometimes that word has negative
connotations but in reality
it's cool to be punk you it's cool to
turn and run and avoid a fight
like that's punk rock dude a physical
fight you choose to avoid
yeah a battle of ideas and a culture war
you need
to know well like you said you don't
play their level man you you stay punk
you stay on your level no you yeah
because if you do that i definitely
think that analogy is missing missing
out what we're doing is literally
fighting back as hard as we can well
like you said if someone's like
well what about z you just keep talking
about why but that's still fighting
you're just not letting them dictate the
time i'm not the fight that's not
rock i'm gonna violate your rules that
i'm punk you know i'm not gonna fight
the alligator underwater like you said
i'm not
gonna stand on land and be like you want
to go i'm up here on the drag the
chicken
up the bank and when the alligator gets
out there i'll beat him to death with a
baseball bat
all right that's what we're gonna do but
he's still gonna fight it because he's
evil and i want him done
and he's trying to shut us down i'm
gonna starve him out or something yeah
there's other ways to win a war
i'm talking about punk rock in the sense
of fighting the establishment
and telling the the the the the nerds
the boring people the authoritarians
the npcs to buzz off we're going to do
our thing
we're going to make fun exciting content
young people are going to want to be a
part of it they're going to be inspired
by it by the talent
by the by the enterprise and they're
going to look to these woke boring
teachers who tell them what they can or
can't do and they're going to be like i
choose freedom so
no laugh track no definitely okay good
have a live audience just have enough of
it no no it's it's
like it's going to be it's going to like
i mean maybe we could do a laugh track
on purpose first no i just
brooklyn nine-nine we're we're it's
gonna be a modern modern show
it's gonna be that should be the name of
it too modern show the modern
comedy show perfect no no there's a
pitch for it it's it's already it's
someone else's project starting out
i've already got an outline and so i'm
asking i'm being asked to fund it
and i was like i'll buy the show you
make it we'll put it on timcast.com for
members only i'm interested jimin to
hear your
your tactics to win this to preempt the
civil war because i think of it as a
long-term game with the chinese you know
an 80-year plan to subvert our culture
by feeding things to our children
so i'm kind of thinking in that same
realm like
i don't want to go head at it because
that's what they want me to do they want
me to come straight at them so they can
ban me for something
you have to do some of that but first of
all i'll say one of the first things you
should do make comedy shows
right make our culture popular because
right now
they're the the authoritarian jerks that
nobody likes we're the cool kids
so let's be the cool kids let's make
good movies ben shapiro's people the
daily wire that run hide shoot movie
was a good it was a great movie and not
a great movie by conservatives
it was a great action flick and that
chick was a
can i say bad yeah i could say badass
i don't want to get you thrown up she
was a badass it was a great movie i was
on the edge of my seat
infidel by dinesh d'souza yeah another
great movie
not just a great show by a conservative
yeah oh wow and
and it was it was an action flick you
know jim caviezel in a in a prison
getting rescued life comes in with a
helicopter it was
bad ass your comedy show i guarantee is
going to be badass
because you wouldn't make it otherwise
you wouldn't do it in some of these
comics i'm just like oh these guys
they push it so hard good george carlin
that's punk rock george carlin got
arrested
for his bit the seven words you can't
say on tv you gotta be arrested for that
they don't do that today but they'll ban
you to go see george carlin
wow literally i had because we had to
travel far enough to do it that was punk
rock
yeah but that's just it that's the first
thing you do is create
things that aren't woke but are cool
all right because that's the thing the
right has always been uptight well
what's up tight is statists telling you
how to live your life
so what's the antidote to that liberty
loving people who are are cool and
having a good time you wanna know
something crazy
this is this is this kind of this kind
of pisses me off uh
so a lot of people most people know i've
been skateboarding for several decades
and uh i've i know a bunch of pro
skateboarders
and they won't they don't want to come
they don't want to come and film
segments they don't want to confiscate
the ramp they're scared you know why
skateboarding is mainstream culture it
is corporate
and it is while not the biggest industry
in the world and not the wealthiest and
not the most mainstream
during the olympics baby they got big
brand sponsors they do big multi-million
dollar events
so i'm like i'm talking to this guy and
like man i love your show i love what
you do and i was like you want to come
from a segment they're like dude
i just we can't get a target on us i get
i get all
i get the other the the other action
sports i could call it
we have one dude who was like i'm a you
know bmx writer and i come to film a
segment i'm like okay it looks like
we're gonna do bmx
this guy this guy made this youtube
video i want to come and do some tail
whips in your park and i'm like
let's make it happen now we're gonna put
up videos on the website these ones will
be free and we'll share
like here's a dude you know we're we
what i want to do with this with the
space we have because we have something
we call the grind bar
we set up the skate park in the in the
garage it's big and you can actually
ollie up
onto a ledge and then ollie onto the bar
which jump up on okay i should just say
jump because it could be any sport
but you can grind across the bar itself
so we're gonna film these challenges
and we're gonna have fun and be punk
rock and play music and i gotta say it's
hard to get the skateboarders to do it
because their sponsors are big
mainstream corporations
the smaller less popular action sports
no offense to inline skaters or to
bmxers
they don't got nearly as many followers
or big sponsors so they're like dude i'm
totally down when i was young i used to
always want i chased the people that had
already made it because i was like if i
can get those people to join me then
it's going to be big and then i realized
nah man i'm just going to make it and
all the people that want to make it with
me
are they going to be the people that in
the future have made it yeah
build build our culture you know and
don't rely on other people to do it
because you can't you can rely on them
trying to kill it
so assume that you have a target on you
already
and build mechanisms to get your message
out and get your entertainment out and
get your views out
that they can't take away from you like
your own website which is another thing
too i hope it's hosted on a boat
somewhere
in the north atlantic so that amazon
can't shut you down
well that's the other thing too is we're
talking about creating this open source
project
to create a uh subscription-based
service that anyone could have on their
own website
yes beautiful people contact me on
twitter direct message if you want to
get involved with that it's very cool
we're setting up a chat room right now
through the matrix
protocol it's going to be an open source
project yeah and so
the idea is you got a website all you
got to do is install the simple open
source package and then people can
become members to your site but all the
sites network with each other so
basically we create a decentralized
network of independent websites
that's exactly how the soviet union went
down they just did it with paper
salmon right that was people passing
information back amongst themselves
underneath
the web of the statist masters now the
other thing you talked about the long
war the long wars education
all right we're dead unless we have an
alternative way
to make sure our kids don't get taught
that america is evil that freedom is bad
you know and that they have to believe
the woke bible so you got to work on
that you know and that's that's a
long-term project that's a generational
war
they've been at it for several
generations that's why we've got the
problems we do
so you got to do that you got to stand
up for free speech
all right so you got to do three things
you got to get the education you're free
speech and you have to have popular
culture
right which are the things they took
away from us i used to think internet
video alone
would be enough to educate people that
they would the information's there
so they will find it but now i'm finding
it's guided you know people are guided
towards especially with al
social media algorithms people are being
guided towards specific types of
information
but yeah you can set up your own for for
schools though
i i do wonder how many of these kids in
schools are hearing their teacher say
you want to be a woke anti-racist and
these students are going wow
i want to be just like teacher i can't
imagine there's a lot of kids who are
like that
that's the other thing people are not
paying attention to is is the pendulum
swings back and forth that you rebel
against authority who's the authority
now the status authoritarians
right what what do kids hate more than
anything being told what they have to do
right so we're gonna see that that's
what we need to take advantage of that's
available
it's what's what's past gen z millennial
jen double z
gen zed zed i don't know hey i
incidentally i'm staking a claim
jen a1 no i am the lead dog of gen
x all right oh nice the people claim
this 1965 is october 1964
because i am the first member of gen x
and my crew is in power now
and we invented all the sports that are
now lame you know all the skydiving and
skateboard flips that are crazy stuff
that are now lamely corporate
oh the sports aren't like no but but the
corporatism of them is
but we invented that because we rebelled
i was thinking about how crazy this is
though because i was i was i was
listening to tony hawk talk about being
a skateboarder and how hard it was
in the 80s you were a loser yeah you
were weirdos doing this thing
nobody was you're supposed to play
football or basketball or baseball
because now sports now it's the olympics
now it's it's red bull and these big
corporations even
even a lot of snowboarding too it's just
it's surprising to me how
boring it's become for real because it's
not dangerous anymore because it's
become corporatized
right and that's good and now that those
people are scared let's pick
other ones pick a new sport you know
there's some crazy thing pick airsoft
you know you know
i saw your guns airsoft yeah i thought
it was interesting because there was uh
there are some pros who are like
some people will always complain about
the changing culture of everything
and there are a lot of people who say
skateboarding was better back in the day
and you know to them i would say it just
changed and for kids who are growing up
in today are going to be very happy with
skateboarding and that's true
i'm just talking about toeing the line
i'm talking about pros
who used to be like i'm going to go
skate this bank where you literally you
can get arrested for being on private
property
now it's a lot of park now you've got
like the olympics
are are coming up and so there's this
big competition anyone in the united
states apparently can enter by
submitting a 45 second run
in a you know it doesn't have to be in a
park but it needs to incorporate park
terrain
basically this means everyone's going to
be in a skate park skating
whereas skateboarding for for the
longest time was being out in the
streets and conquering terrain urban
terrain
it was almost urban exploration in a
sense but that was
vandalism you know it was it was punk
rock you were going out you were telling
the security guards to f off i'm not a
fan of that by the way you're supposed
to leave and then come back later you
don't you know fight with people
uh because people get hurt but you'd
like put wax on a ledge in front of a
building
it a long term it would scuff it up and
discolor it but they didn't care
it wasn't your property they didn't care
it was punk rock it was edgy it was
disrespectful in other ways
it's there's still a bit of that street
skating culture but it's become very
corporate
and it's like yeah it's not really
interesting to be another cog in the
giant machine
i just i i think it's it's time to
create new ideas new cultures new
concepts maybe airsoft is the thing we
should be filming
video gaming is one that used to be so
nerdy
and uncool like in the 80s i was the
they called me nintendo crossland in
elementary
school and i was like the dork but like
now people are multi-millionaire
superstars gaming giant
you know i mean it's it's one of the
biggest industries in the world and i
think it's just going to get cooler and
then it eventually it has kind of been
corporatized you know amazon owns twitch
and it's kind of dictating what people
can say but man there are some punk rock
if you watch gamers stream the things
they will say
like if you want to tap into the child's
psyche
you know twitch sent me an email because
i've got an account everywhere because i
have to
and they literally said this is the new
things we're going to de-platform people
that happen off twitch yep i got that
too
i'm social credit scoring dude exactly
and that's that's where
these people will rebel so we have the
ability to go ahead and appeal to people
who don't like to be told what to do
which is basic libertarianism you know
it's not a governing philosophy
but it's a personal philosophy and you
can tell those people if you want to be
left alone to enjoy your life
you should be hanging out with us
because if you hang out with the woke
crew
though you can't ever get the rules
right what rules how you ever gonna
follow
all the rules of wokeness because they
change every time
someone else pops up and one of the
rules is we can ban you at any time for
no reason
literally for no reason at any time who
wants to play with that game that's
that's ridiculous
garbage go look for my twitter feed and
i'm not there because
i say things that they don't like and i
kick their butts you know and and that's
that's pathetic so
let's appeal to the people who don't
like that and here's the nice thing the
the woke people are helping us
because look at what's happening with
blacks and latinos from the last
election
all right people talk about we got
killed in the election we picked up 12
house seats for the republicans and more
black and latino votes than
ever before for trump of all people they
said he was a racist
exactly now why is that it's because
they watched those riots and everything
last year and those are working class
people
who have jobs they lost their jobs
because of kovid
when the when the democrats locked them
down and they
businesses were burnt down by blm and
antifa
and that made him mad and they're like
where are the police
why aren't the police coming to help me
right i thought they were the good guys
like no
no defund the police the police are evil
police hate you hate the police like i
don't hate the police i hate criminals i
hate gangs
i got to pull up this chart i love
pulling this [ __ ] this chart up oh yeah
before
the george floyd riots black lives
matter enjoyed 17
net support in this country after
uh the george floyd incident it spiked
23
net support something then happened do
you know what happened as you know right
after this the spark of the george floyd
story what happened in this country
what what did people start doing no no
no no what what was the direct response
to the death of george floyd among them
bought guns no riots yeah okay they
started going around bernie sanders and
then everyone else bought guns
the net support then dropped to seven
percent currently today net support for
black lives matter is at six
percent a year out you get it it is
almost
it is 40 i believe let's see let's uh
let's go back to the beginning of last
year was at around
not it was eight nine percent so it's
down between you know
20 to 35 percent net support it's made
me feel good man
that's that's wonderful news because
they're a recruiter for our team they're
a recruiter for the team that likes
freedom and liberty
not a bunch of angry racists
telling us that the rest of us are
racist don't project onto me
and tell me how to live my life
beautiful let's let's uh
i'll make sure to yeah like don't mess
with your enemy while they're making a
mistake
exactly yeah and they're going to do it
again i kind of feel for this black
lives matter movement in a way because i
feel like antifa
got their tentacles all wrapped up in it
and did a lot of violence just like
angry violent anarchists just kind of
used that movement
and got involved in a way that wasn't
the intention
from the beginning of not that i was i
was there at some of the first black
lives matter protests it was always the
same people
antifa for the most part is just the
flag they use
it's far leftists of various persuasions
who wear all black and go around
engaging in violence
and before we called them antifa we just
call them the black bloc
it was a reference to the same leftist
protesters activists extremists we've
always known
and when i was in new york at the
trayvon martin protest they were there
as well
the same people now fly the antifa flag
same people
and then and the black lives matter
protest no matter how well-intentioned
some of them may be
you've always got the young angry crowd
that wants to break stuff
and so those two groups would meld
together and they create like the ball
of ugliness and somebody would break a
window and then it's gone from there
but the the bad part is and i think the
good thing for us
is that they now have busted their brand
their brand is violence now it's working
in intimidating local leaders but it's
not working and gaining public support
it's pushing normals toward us the
working class normal people
now i think that's an interesting
coalition i just outlined we've got
the punk rock radical cool kids now
hanging out with the normal working
class folks
but we're all the ones who say we know
how to live our lives you don't tell us
how to live our lives
and we'll take care of business i love
cryptocurrency because it's so punk rock
and like
internet developers so punk rock like
they are
building the future cool i'm in
yeah no guarantees but there's a it's a
big reason why a lot of
anarchists bought into bitcoin very
early on oh yeah not leftian or kiss
because they don't believe in money i
guess but all the right anarchists got
super rich
they were like it's money the government
doesn't know about i'll buy it all
smart and then they they went ahead and
created a new way to do business which
we're allowed to do
and again to your point of let's create
shows and let's do other things
and new sports and other things that
popularize what we're doing from our
side
and guess what we are going to be much
more entertaining
and inviting than the other side because
you can tell they're angry because we
have human they're unpleasant
we can tell jokes we mock people and
it's fun
you know but we but it's it's like
insulting and disparaging people for the
sake of being mean is not fun
but playfully ripping at each other over
you know stereotypes and other dumb
ideas is fun it's fun and funny
because we're all part of the same jokes
we're all being made fun of we're all on
on a level playing field with each other
so could we have stand-up comedy back
then
could we literally because they've
killed that dude for authentic purposes
ryan long though he's amazing he's he's
nailing it but what's he doing
he's mocking woke culture he's found
he's found the magic bullet
but he's got he's you know these videos
he makes
often do most of the time but he also
has a stand-up routine he has a bunch of
other jokes
uh i think he recently did a joke about
the nsa
watching watching dudes whack off like
he's not making fun of the woke
he's just a funny guy he's a funny dude
and he and he makes fun of the woke and
it's funny too
and there that's the nice thing is when
you can mock your enemy
you hurt them more than you ever can
with any kind of violence or anger or
anything else
you you delegitimize them because you
don't take them seriously
and they're they're so good you know
they mock themselves you can't you can't
hardly caricature
he does and he does it well but that's
just it they are so absurd
that and there's so much ammo there that
if more people take that up
guess what you've got now we need a
daily show
from the right yeah you know looking at
the bible yeah
yeah you got crowded yeah every morning
yeah all right well how about we go to
super chats everybody if you haven't
already
help out the show by smashing that like
button because it really does help
and when you comment and like you're
basically telling youtube you like the
show so we really appreciate
it but if you want to see some cultural
stuff get created and we're gonna do it
go to timcast.com become a member we're
gonna have a bonus segment coming up
later tonight as well
we have a big library of content at this
point of all of these different shows
you can't get anywhere else from awesome
people
so help out the show don't forget to
like share subscribe we're about to
crack
one million subscribers so probably in
the next week or week or so
we'll be at a million subscribers on
this channel so you guys rock thank you
so much for all the support
and everything uh and all the likes and
the comments and uh
if you're listening on itunes spotify
leave us a good review we're going to
read y'all super chats and see what you
guys have to say
all right let's see mesotrashed
miso trashed that's what it says you
should invite your mama to talk about
her life i think it would be good for
people to hear her story
and for you to have the rest of uh you
have for the rest of your life
uh maybe it depends on you know i'm not
sure
people in my family want to be very
publicly known especially with the
craziness of the far left right
that's fair matthew hammond says tim get
simon mann the british former
army officer turned mercenary when
travel from england opens up
there are a lot of people in england i
would love to have on the show so many
in canada
not easy to get yeah
raymond fields says i love the quote the
2a is made for hunting and not weapons
of war argument
it was made so we can have weapons of
war to overthrow a tyrannical government
well i want to clarify this too because
a lot of people tend to say this that
the second amendment is about defending
you know defending the united states
from a tyrannical government
it was for any oppressor anyone it was
about defending the free state
it could be a foreign or domestic enemy
so don't limit yourself
your gun rights are for everything those
canadians might get all hopped up on
molson's and tim horton donuts
and screaming across the border on
snowmobiles yeah well a lot of us are
the native americans too
i mean definitely let's not deny that
that was a giant genocide
but let's also not forget that the
canadians may uh uh
gort what's the one thing gorge
themselves on on poutine and by the time
they get they're too sluggish yeah and
maple syrup
they're stuck to the border
all right let's see rogue ryan says i
wish i was getting paid fifty thousand
dollars to smoke parmesan and send them
the board for my last name
i do not understand u.s lefties i hear
you
bro i hear you i would smoke parmesan
for 50 grand
100 that sounds fine tastes good
kickstarter we doing a kickstarter
let's do it
release the craggle says the second
amendment is an inalienable right it's
absolute we are done handing over our
rights to appease those who know nothing
about them
we want peace but we are prepared for
war
but it will be if we protect it the
matador says shall not be infringed was
not a suggestion it's a statement
gun laws is infringing that's right
taxation is theft that's right let's do
it oh let's get into it
i mean i think people need to you want
to change the constitution if you want
to get rid of those
second if you've got a promise like an
amendment you don't just pass laws that
violate
our constitutional rights go ahead and
pass an amendment or have a
constitutional convention
and then if i don't like the outcome
guess what that's why i bought my guns
all right i don't have to agree to your
new constitution if you change it so
foo nation says this is for ian i was
brave enough to check out crypto because
of you keep being your interdimensional
self that's awesome dude and yes we are
vibrating
apparently in the vacuum you're
interdimensional yeah we all
are everybody am i yeah no not like a
vibrational
joke i have to get in touch the joke was
that we had a new a new employee start
and they
every time they came ian was not around
and so he was like i'm convinced ian's
not real
and we're like that's right ian's just
an astral projection he's not really
here
i was i was talking about ian today i
was like have you seen ian yeah and he
goes
ian i was like yeah it's a suffix
yeah yeah exactly yes i don't know blake
is real
blake larum says i appreciate your
insight and diversity of guests you
provide unbiased views and intellectual
dialogue that's not available in the
mainstream media
wow that's a compliment thank you so
much diversity of ideas not just
skin color and chromosomes super fun
that's weird
all of the above weird war movie vet
says hey tim you missed your chance to
have a good show when you turned down
gavin mcinnes
i strongly recommend you have him on if
you truly believe in free speech and
ignore msm lies
i don't recall ever turning down gavin
mcinnes from coming on the show
maybe he was too hopped up on poutine
right yeah no he never turned him down
no no way
i gotta i love him by the way he's
hilarious man he is rough around but
he's he pushes it too hard he angered a
lot of people but i
was on the bottom man i really like that
guy somebody's got to go too far
yep and he's always you figure out where
the line is i suppose i mean he's
i'm with him on probably 90 plus 95
percent of the stuff and then that last
five percent i'm like dude
keith mccracken says long time third
time yesterday with prescription drugs
like adderall
i was put on it when i was a preteen and
it really messed with my psyche
mental health starts with diet love you
all thank you for all what
thank you for what you do and uh i'll
make my drive home better
hey thanks man all right that's on point
says 2a is the hell to die on
without that we have no rights or it's
the hill to live on so you can shoot
downhill
yeah that's right i live on a hill
all right let's see what we got hi leaf
says
hi tim great show had a friend who lives
in hawaii and have a question
why is hawaii not used as the gun
control push since they have heavy gun
control
plus my friend also said that you are a
sellout well that's good news i'm not
sure about the hawaii thing though
uh the hawaii thing is they they had a
ruling in the ninth circuit
that hawaii won't allow carry of any
kind right
and they ban it and so it's going to go
to the supreme court and probably be
overturned and it's going to lead to
a a good idea on where they stand on
concealed carry reciprocity and some
other major issues so it was a bad
ruling by the ninth
which they're prone to and a good one
because it'll go to supreme court
and should get its ass kicked this is
interesting someone someone mentioned in
the chat that youtube is suppressing
likes
i don't know that's true but i can say
that we've lost 2 000 likes in the past
five minutes or so
and i was just like well whatever you
know you lose likes you gain likes but i
also just
checked on the on the youtube back end
and the show has also been
hard to monetize so i wonder uh i wonder
what we said they're not happy with you
no i'm just kidding i don't know none of
us said anything
you know maybe we just roll up we load
the van with weapons we roll to silicon
valley man
they're asking for no no no i'm not
serious about that
tim does not believe in violence terry
presley says volley fire is not full
auto it's a single trigger pull
discharging multiple chambers at once or
in rapid succession
full auto fire cycles and fires multiple
times in one
or multiple chambers with one trigger
pull now
yes perhaps technically but uh you know
the point i'm trying to make is that we
had
guns that could shoot multiple rounds
with one trigger pull i understand it
was a bunch of different
you know barrels or whatever you win the
technical
and you lose on the substance of it
all right billy deerhead says attach an
omnidirectional camera and microphone to
a drone
connect connected to a vr headset and
microphones a harness to suspend
yourself off the floor
and controls in the hands to guide the
drone thus simulating flying in the real
world
we are we are working on the zeppelin
project minus the harness but yeah
that's the first step
so for the longest time wikipedia
claimed i invented a zeppelin camera
because wikipedia is this is just broken
and stupid
and they finally removed it because i
kept complaining saying i'd never
invented the zeppelin thing
once that now that's removed i decided
you know i'm actually going to fund the
creation of this zeppelin project so
we're actually going to start building
this
that way they'll be forced to put it
back it looks like an 18-footer is the
way to go
to be able to handle the weight that we
need for our first run yeah we want to
build the live broadcast from a zeppelin
so people can log online and watch a
hi-def live stream
from the from the zeppelin so you can do
news coverage in the air without without
helicopter or a person
i'm in yeah it's not hard to do it's
it's like seriously probably a couple
hours to get done
no joke we might need to be out we
getting the the signal it will be the
trickier part but i think we can easily
do something with
uh cellular bonding over 4g or something
3g 3g it looks like we're going to start
3g
i think 3g is the way to go to start
with that's what andreas was saying but
is there still 3g tech
i don't know you get arduin arduino is
that what they're called
and then you get a little i don't know
he was showing me all the pieces and
parts last night
looks like everybody's fighting back and
giving us a bunch of likes because
keep liking guys but don't like only
like it an odd number of times or if you
click the like button click it twice
it'll unlike no that is weird
before we do super chats we had over ten
thousand likes i think it was like 11 or
something
and then all of a sudden i started
watching go down as if people were
unliking the video
so i was like maybe maybe someone said
something we're getting dislikes now
and then so i checked over on the
youtube dashboard and i'm like no
there's
there's no dislikes there's like very
few so there are dislikes they're just
coming from silicon valley
no i mean like yeah
how did we lose 2 000 likes if people
just decided to remove the like from the
video i guess that's weird
my social media credit score infected
you're like
no capabilities hey it happens it
happens
all right let's see where are we at
uh oh samantha fitzgerald says ian can't
say
concentration camps are evil what the
hell well like
what's the difference concentration
means that they're killing people so
southern border aren't concentration
camps they're internment camps
i'd never i mean if you think of a
concentration camp as a place where you
put innocent people to kill them then
yeah that's evil
but then you've got to define innocent
because in a time of war enemy civilians
can be considered
combatants bo jess says ian not
everything is subjective lots of things
are
are objectively bad stop being still
leftist well then give me one
here we go totally bad yeah johnny arson
says liber
but not in war that's not murder that's
not an order all you gotta do is sign on
a piece of paper and it's no longer
murder that's still not murder what so
if someone says it's okay to kill then
it's okay
ian do you think like war is fought
because someone's like you know i just
feel like killing
sometimes what's happening in most
instances of war
is that there's a threat to the status
quo or structure
and due to that threat somebody feels
it's within their
necessity to go and you know kill
somebody sometimes
now the issue though is where i'll agree
with you is when the military-industrial
complex lobbies
a bunch of crappy corporatist senators
and politicians
to vote for war so that our young men
and women go and die
for nothing but in the general concept
of war is not
the same thing as murder and there's
just war theory all right you could say
war being can be good or bad all right
if you have a just war and that's that's
an objective thing you can say
you can say there are some wars that
were definitely some words are conquest
wars of conquest are wrong and evil but
a war of self-defense
again written by the victors right you
get to write the history
but you can base it on what they were
doing and who they were doing it too
if you fight a war to stop something bad
from happening
then you're doing an objective good how
about how about how about selling drugs
to kids
like adderall no no like like street
drugs like hard narcotics hard opiates
fentanyl i mean adderall is a hardener
a hard opiate i asked you about fentanyl
no that's you don't think it's evil to
give a kid fentanyl
yeah i think that would be well is that
objectively evil i think so
it's just you've laid me a very vague
situation
you asked if there are some things that
are objectively evil as a painkiller
a tiny tiny tiny dose i didn't say that
no no no no selling drugs to kids would
you
say it is evil for a dude to grab a
seven-year-old by the hair and
jam a lethal dose of fentanyl down his
throat and hold his mouth shut yeah but
what if the seven year old had a grenade
in his hand and was coming up to you to
blow you up
and it's self-defense and it's not did i
did i ask you to define the situation
and you're a constructivist no i'm
saying these are subjective in reality
you are wrong because no one gave you
killing is killing is always wrong
unless it's right
is that what you're saying no what
you're doing is definitely right
sometimes sometimes it would be wrong to
not kill
you see ian what you don't understand
because you're a constructivist is that
when i lay out the parameters
you've decided to change the parameters
you said to kill a kid
i said a guy grabs a seven-year-old yeah
by the back of the hair and shoves a
lethal dose of fentanyl down his throat
and holds his mouth shut
sure is that evil well is that he a
soldier in vietnam i didn't i didn't
tell you
you didn't know you didn't tell me it
doesn't matter it does matter context
matters no
in what you're doing is you're changing
the parameters
because you can't accept because you
didn't give me any so i'm creating them
so if you watched a guy on the street
walk up to a seven-year-old pull his
hair back and shove that on
start you say maybe it's a good thing
well now you've given me some parameters
no that doesn't sound like a good thing
what what primers did i give you that it
was on the street i pictured new york
city but what if the kid was a terrorist
ian well if it comes out why did you
then remember
okay so you just said it was wrong the
pro see the problem with it
but i'm not going to throw the guy i'm
not problem with construction during
execution and the things
you do in arguments like this is that
you could be asked a simple question and
you decide to change
the argument the reason we have courts
is because we don't know if it's right
and wrong
at first glance what what first glance
we have to look into things and find out
context and see maybe show us what
looked evil wasn't it to decide
punishment that's not to decide whether
it was right or wrong sometimes we're
deciding whether or not we're to punish
somebody
for what they did it was objectively
right or wrong when they did it
and that's the difference is you have to
be able to say some things are
objectively evil
at the point they're happening and i
would just say if i was going to kill a
seven-year-old terrorist
i wouldn't dose them with fentanyl the
point is there are various
obviously things that are objectively
evil that no human would agree with
unless they're
unless they're broken in the head i
don't know man destruction is such a way
of life for humans
that we've kind of accepted it and and
it just depends on who you ask you know
you know what i hear when you say these
things ian
you are you have have evil tendencies
that you've expressed before that you
want to justify
it my core i'm a philosopher and i
understand that
it's it's too easy to say something is
blatantly right blatantly wrong without
taking context into account
but okay you asked hold on you can look
at some things and say
this is immediately objectively wrong
in the context that i see right now i
think there are situations
yeah like if you see someone put their
hand on a burner and start screaming i
would take their hand off the burner
i would think that's bad you asked are
there things that are objectively evil
the answer is yes when i gave you an
example
you changed the argument in order to
justify
someone being evil do you understand
that's constructivism
if a guy walked up how about that dude
in new york
who drove up to a guy was walking his
four-year-old daughter shot daughter
shot him and killed him is that evil
what happened a guy was crossing a
crosswalk with his four-year-old
daughter and a car pulled up stopped the
guy pulled up the gun shot
and killed him yeah sounds awful
objectively evil
i wasn't there man it sounds awful you
can't say that it's objectively evil to
randomly gun down a man with his
four-year-old daughter just crossing the
street minding his own business
do you see the problem evil you've got
evil's view as hell dude you are the
banality of evil you define the banality
of evil
i mean you define how can i even defend
that that bland
vague statement what does that even mean
the banality why are you looking for
context that would justify it as opposed
to saying
absent context that doesn't justify it
it is e
because i've seen people do horrible
things in the name of good
the banality of evil was when the nazis
didn't care what they were doing because
there must have been some justification
for the orders they were given
that's your mentality not mine when i
see a guy pull up in a car
and gun down a man with his daughter and
this happened in new york i say
that is evil now after the fact we can
investigate and try and figure things
out
but based on what we witness and what we
saw it was an act of evil
even if this dad had wronged this guy in
some way even if he was
an angry violent person or a gang member
pulling up in a car
and then gunning a guy down in cold
blood and broad daylight with his
four-year-old daughter is evil
pure evil and i can say that
and let's just add the context that the
person was not doing anything that
justified
them being killed they were not in a
situation where killing them
was an act of self defense or anything
else it was just a purely evil thing to
do
right i think it you can then you could
say then your arguments move but
it's it no longer becomes if you start
to define all the parameters now you're
creating a subjective situation
no no what you're doing is you're trying
to justify evil by changing parameters
that we're never going through i'm
saying that killing a child is not
objectively evil if the kid's going to
kill you
then you and you kill him in
self-defense it's not evil but
you're just saying tim's asking can you
create one
situation that is objective i think
about this a lot i think about
objectivity and subjectivity a lot
we've had this argument in private
sometimes it's i love this argument but
i don't know man i don't know i think
it's very dangerous to to
lie and die on a hill where you believe
something always is this way
that's not what we said you asked for
one situation in which something could
be objective i didn't i said that i
don't think there are situations like
that
so there's one example a guy pulling up
to a man walking on the street his
four-year-old daughter and [ __ ] him
and killing him
for no reason and it happened it
happened in new york last year
that's random act of violence i don't
know why the guy just decided to kill a
man in front of his child
and the little girl had to run with her
dad dying in the street she had to run
panicking
sorry man some things are evil you see
the problem is you know i i was just
watching star trek it's fantastic
the episode that was just on was about
the the the uh
an admiral was was secretly placed
aboard
brought to the enterprise because there
was a 12 year old ship called the
pegasus
that was engaging in a a technology
experimental technology that could have
reignited intergalactic war
and riker second in command was was it
was explained was chosen
because he defied the orders of one of
his commanding officers
and when picard saw that he was willing
to stand up for what he believed is
right
even though he was being ordered to do
something that was the kind of officer
he wanted on his ship
why there's a reason why i like the next
generation they recognize
that someone could say i want you to do
x
and in your mentality which has been
used to justify genocide for generations
for eons for millennia
the person says i just trust that
there's some justification for why i'm
going to commit an atrocity
whereas a strong-willed person who
believes that some things are inherently
wrong we'll look the look look there
commanding officer in the eyes and say
i will not do that but there are a lot
of people
a lot of cops especially they'll be told
go shoot that kid
and they'll be like yes sir not
everybody's that crazy though and there
are a lot of people are going to say i
ain't doing that are you nuts
but some people just say there must be
some justification for this i suppose
it's not objectively wrong to go kill
that kid that's crazy to me
even if the kid you know this is one of
the biggest challenges the ethical
conundrums that we have when it comes to
war
because the terrorists have been putting
bombs on children and placing them in
roads
like i'm sure you've heard these stories
i have friends that were overseas in
iraq and they said one of the scariest
things is
when you're driving in a vehicle and
you're ordered don't stop for this kid
who's standing in the middle of the road
you know why they put bombs on them what
do you do
man some of these situations are just
nightmares that you have to fight
through
some of our nightmares but then there
are some circumstances where someone
would panic and say just kill him anyway
and the person that said i'm going to
drive around
him no i'm not doing that you got to
make a decision it's not always that
easy
sometimes things are just are just
objectively wrong and you have to say i
won't do that and i won't assume
there's some justification for an
atrocity if someone told me to do
something
you better justify that to me because
otherwise i'm not gonna they don't do
that in the military they don't have to
they're not supposed to
oh no because you're required to disobey
an unlawful order and an
order to commit an atrocity is unlawful
right
by its definition running a kid over
that is assumed to have a bomb on him is
an
atrocity it is atrocious it's not
a war crime now and but here's the thing
when you make that decision you're bound
by did the kid have a bomb on him
yeah you have to believe truly in your
heart that they did
and that that's the only way you could
deal with that situation
and if you do that it was an atrocious
act but it was not atrocity because you
didn't do it
out of an a desire to commit evil you
did it out of desire to save lives
the lives of your men your you know the
people your troops
when when it comes to the historical
genocides
just doing my job or just following
orders was was the justification for
for so many people who committed crimes
that's why people in the military
like you said it's a requirement to
disobey unlawful orders
there are people who go to prison for
committing crimes while they're in war
some things are just objectively wrong
and we take into account i know a lot of
soldiers who are angry about it they're
like it's crazy the amount of rules we
have to follow that they don't
yeah maybe it's because we're the good
guys isn't that funny maybe it's because
the bad guys will blow up a kid
if it means they can gain a piece of
land and we won't do that
we only do it when we're absolutely
desperate have no choice and it's
nightmarish and then you just go to
prison
so we've got all these moral constraints
on us long story short
the societies that say i will lead
people to a gas chamber
there must be some justification for it
if you didn't
if you were told to do something and you
said there's no justification for this
you wouldn't do it
you would say that's inherently evil i
won't do that too many people too many
would just blindly follow and commit
atrocities that's why i don't like this
idea man
that everything is subjective yes
sometimes you can find a reason why a
certain circumstance and i'll tell you
the perfect the perfect like
the point of that entire argument i gave
you an example of when
killing a kid was not objectively evil
the point is
there are instances where it is
objectively evil and there are instances
where it isn't
but it is objectively evil when a serial
killer kidnaps a kid
and then murders them lights their body
on fire for no reason other than they
just wanted to watch the kid burn sorry
that's evil
but like when you say there are
situations when killing a kid is
objectively evil and their situation is
going objectively not that that is
illogical if it's objective then it's
killing a kid is x
that's the objective you're saying you
can't have specific instances that are
objectively
or not you have to have just general
that's when they become subjective the
specifics make sense
a single instance of objectivity it's
not it doesn't have to be an entire
class of actions
either are or aren't and and just
because there are different
contexts in a specific instance doesn't
mean it's subjective
you're still taking an objective view at
that one particular instance
johnny cash shot a man in rito just to
watch him die
that was evil all right johnny cash did
johnny cash did that he that's what he
told me
crazy we got to read more super chats
cause we got this great distracted
argument caden peterson says hey tim
been watching for years after observing
the political sphere for that time
i've written a sci-fi novel with the
themes of modern day
it is 2084 to 2069 on amazon keep up the
good work will do thank you
all right the raptors talent says first
time super chat hope this works
i've always viewed justice as a balance
between the absolute power of law
and the personal vengeance of the victim
based on this policy
i don't think that any trial against the
establishment will work
interesting
student of history says the one one ring
equals power
power corrupts uh i
okay uh death camps were state certified
aoc go explain
that to the jews in nyc joe biden has no
idea what he's talking about from
history
founding fathers would drool at an ar ak
also if jbp equals red skull well g d
me well hail hydra
it's hard because it's awesome people
people try to cram so much in super
chats when you guys start doing acronyms
and stuff i can't decipher what you know
you're trying to mean when you do
acronyms and things like that
jpb jordan b peterson there you go oh
yeah yeah yeah we'll talk about them uh
maybe
maybe in the uh members only
a super guy says good news on the
two-way front arizona just passed a bill
to defy federal firearms or regulations
governor abbott
will sign similar legislation in texas
and my own state of oklahoma has a
two-way sanctuary bill that made it to
the house
wow nice rosie riveter says
antifa here also former owm
i realized that i realized the real
agenda of antifa i left as soon as i
as soon as i left as soon as i left the
death threats
came in i'm thankful every day i woke up
keep spreading the truth you guys are
amazing appreciate it that's
awesome occupy walls i see how that
sentiment lingered from occupy wall
street
into antifa i feel that thomas cutler
says tim will you have joe rogan on your
show
joe can come to my house whenever he
would like and come on at any time
and i'm sure the man is just much too
busy eating elk
he definitely eats elk but i mean the
dude is running a massive empire i love
that like even even smaller youtubers
it's hard to get them out here because
they do their own show
but uh i of course would invite joe
rogan on the show it's just he's a busy
guy
he's more than welcome to come and hang
out whenever he wants we'll get him to
drop in on the six foot
m sheba says give this to ian he is
putting in the work with the witty
banter tonight
hey there you go nova zero says nick
requieta's take on right written house
is awesome
the statute would have made it illegal
for kyle to have held a gun
that doesn't apply to long arms kyle
carried a long arm
kyle did nothing wrong love love the pod
whale cast
thank you see hammond says evil
sentient intelligence expending
purposeful efforts in order to
artificially manufacture unnecessary
suffering
onto another sentient intelligence for
the sole purpose of its own pleasure
that was outstanding yeah
nicely played yeah yeah some things are
just evil man
melty samich says it's odd how the state
follows the 13th amendment to the letter
but the second amendment is contorted to
what the elites want it to be
the man the myth the legend rapper
killer mike would be a great guest he
would be yeah he's right yeah
i'll look him up no it's funny like the
13th amendment allows the state to keep
slaves so long as they've been convicted
of a crime
well that one whoa there's no argument
there there should be
second amendment though we got all these
all these arguments man does that mean i
can quarter my friends who are still in
the military in any house i want now
because finally
yeah absolutely the third amendment just
thinking
right out supply says heard you talking
about getting some bmx riders to the
skatepark
last night sent you a dm on instagram
about some of your sp some of our
sponsored writers let's link up
uh i have like 50 billion messages on
instagram i can't go through them
so uh i don't know the best way to email
the contact because we just have so many
emails but um
okay you can send it to spin the ufo and
then try to take down the enforce post
yeah
uh also some uh obviously pro
skateboarders are welcome the ones i've
asked are just kind of scared because
it's such a big sport
there's a lot of risk when you have big
mainstream sponsors but uh
i'll we'll take skiers i don't know i
don't know what you're going to do on a
half pipe but
aggressive inline bmx skateboarding uh
if you've got a pogo stick i mentioned
this the other day
if you've got a pogo stick and you're
real good and you want to you want to
thrash on a half pipe somehow with the
pogo stick
i don't know how you do it but i bet you
could we'd film that too that'd be fun
oh man damien ggj says ian must be
laying off the drugs recently he's been
saying some decent stuff
awesome dude god bless to your team i'm
taking this very seriously
he's high on oxygen that's right he's
high on life have you guys ever got high
on oxygen before
you just breathe really hard for a long
oh yeah yeah it is that's what it is
you're getting high on oxygen hapasan
says re-legalize dueling so whenever
someone is offended they can defend
their honor and the offender can stand
his or her ground and fight back
if needed just kidding thanks tim and
crew ordered my tin foil hat gorilla
shirt two days ago looking forward to it
yes my friends if you go to timcast.com
click that shop button we got
tin foil hat gorilla shirts for a
limited time only
it is very similar to the regular iron
gorilla but he's wearing a tinfoil hat
oh yeah do you know about the iron girl
thing no i was going to ask because alex
jones was here and he kept saying
i am a gorilla he's referencing ishmael
okay
and then uh you know you know ishmael is
this book where like a psychic gorilla
tells humans they're a virus destroying
the planet
no a little bit so alex he just kept
randomly saying i am a gorilla
and so we made a shirt that zama grill
instead of grill on it it's actually the
diamond hand squirrel is right there in
that shirt you can you can see it i
think it's a misprinted version we keep
it here
yeah but this is a little too dark it's
the wall street version oh this is the
one where they made it darker to make it
no no no
no no they did that that wasn't actually
exciting but this one is the diamond
hands gorilla where he got rich off
gamestop stocks
oh nice so he's got cash in his hands
and he's smiling and smoking
all right let's see we got we got a
bunch of super chats
and uh oh man wow a ton just came in
whoa
the whole the whole evil argument
triggered all yeah i thought jim you
made a good point where you said that
there can be
parameters that lead to situations that
could be considered objective
that's an interesting concept it's not
it doesn't have to be 100 broad
on a topic you can limit it yeah
you can have exceptions as well aya
bat says ian's unwillingness to label
evil as evil itself is evil
and then they called in an idiot but i
won't read the rest of them you can't
use the word to define the
word no it's evil to use the word to
define the word isn't it
it's very circuitous i will say that
you can't and there was no harm done yes
true not true that was out of love
maybe stole a little oxygen i mean but i
got high because there was less oxygen
in the room so
thanks man a couple people have
mentioned they became members but are
having trouble logging in just email
members
at timcast.com and we'll fix this and we
have the engineer solving the problem
uh which should be soon never to happen
again it just it just
these things happen and also someone's
uh ghost crusaders wants to know the
email for jobs it's jobs at timcast.com
we are absolutely hiring the issue is we
are a small company and we're hiring fat
we have the ability to hire faster than
we should
and so there's a lot of considerations
when a company grows really really
quickly like
human uh like uh human resources be
challenged to you know deal with
50 new employees all at once so we have
no choice but to have these like
staggered growth but we're looking for
like a news editor
paranormal editor because we're doing
that paranormal podcast and uh yeah i'd
like to find a php
developer that would like to work maybe
on a month by month basis
for the open source project yeah yeah
yeah find me on twitter you find a
journalist and have them learn to code
yeah there you go yeah they learn the
code
all right trying to try it's it's
there's too many super chats and so
youtube's loading really slow
suffering from success over here yeah
brown bear says tim please stop calling
the m1 an iron sight's rifle you can put
a scope on it iron sights is not of
classification
of firearms i'm just saying that like
stock
it doesn't have a picatinny rail that's
probably a better way to put it so what
i'm the point i'm trying to make is that
if you have
an m1a that has nothing but iron sights
it's still an assault weapon
if it has a 10 round magazine it's still
an assault weapon it is wooden stock
long gun doesn't matter what it has or
what it doesn't have i'm just throwing
that distinction and
i appreciate the correction on on the
full specs for the m1a
the point i'm just making is the scar
20s is
a modern ar15 that is totally fine so by
their logic this makes no sense they
want to ban the ar-15 but they ban the
m1
m1a that's ridiculous they got that
backwards it's supposed to be scary
black guns
exactly that's that's it right morons
yeah like a pistol grip on a ruger 10
22. you gotta get rid of that but the
rifle grip is fine
oh my gosh brilliant chainsaw bayonet
though
we're going back to those chainsaws yeah
mike sullivan says tim got to say i love
your show really honest real talk about
real life issues
25-year ems firearms instructor sent you
an email love to come on the show and
talk two-way issues
also love to teach you and your folks
some tac medical skills
before you go on the road that'll be
great man
keegan mooney says first time chat
please make don't fight an alligator
underwater t-shirts
maybe make the alligator look woke af
that's a really good idea
can you write that down we're gonna do
that
i'd wear that that's a good and we'll
we'll quote it to ian that was it that
was a good ian quote it's a nice one
don't fight an alligator underwater i'll
roll you around
yeah yeah it's funny because it seems
obvious all right we'll take a uh
we'll take a couple more uh super chats
there's a there's a wow a lot of super
chats came in talking about evil and
things like that it is a fun debate
it is a deep rooted debate
good someone someone someone made a
statement but i'm gonna ask this
question for the super chat
ian if you had a time machine would you
kill baby hitler no
i thought a lot about that too yeah
because something much worse may have
come about
oh he was a product of his times in many
ways that's what if you just
what if you just what have you just like
hobbled him
might have been even worse he was
already kind of hobbled
the idea that doing something or not
doing something because something worse
might happen
is a gutless move there are times when i
mean it's the trolley paradox
all right if you i'm not going to do the
trolley pictures what if i do it it
derails and 100 000 people get killed
you know you make the decision based on
the context
of the situation you're in and if you
have the opportunity to go and stop
evil you should stop that evil
regardless of whether the potential
that it could be worse exists maybe
though mussolini would have conquered
more of africa and
europe and then the japanese would have
taken russia and there wouldn't have
been a reason for the united states to
get involved with britain and then it
would
be maybe the bavarians would have just
drunk more beer without hitler riley
them all i guess
and been happy just being fat and eating
knock work the argument is i like
i like the way it turned out as vicious
as it was i liked the way that the
allies won the war and i don't want to
mess with that
no i don't know man there's uh i saw a
stat where they said there's two million
less jews alive today than there were in
1939 so
maybe if you could stop all that you try
you know what i mean but here's the
important question here's the important
point ian
you know look you'd l you loved adding
parameters to the arguments
except when it comes to stopping hitler
what's up with that i just added a bunch
of parameters
i could add a parameter okay you can
time travel yeah so you go back and kill
baby hitler and then see what happened
and if it made it worse then you try
something else and kill me
oh and you could go back again and not
kill him oh of course i'd go back and
i don't want to go any further i try all
sorts of crazy stuff if i had an
infinite time machine
i'd buy apple stock
bitcoin yeah bitcoin i'd go back to 2011
and i'd walk into the hacker's space oh
my gosh my buddy advised me not to buy
thousands of bitcoin
ethereum was 89 cents for 20 punches in
the face
no i punched myself in the face why
didn't you buy it
all right everybody smash that like
button thanks so much everybody did
smash the like button it was weird we
were at like 10k likes and then 2000
just disappeared creepy
in the blink of an eye yeah but then
snapped his fingers the
the the awesome viewers just uh just
fixed it so that's great
so uh look smash the like button
subscribe because we're about to break
one million subscribers and i'm gonna
hit up google and be like where's our
gold where's our gold award you gotta
give it to us now cause we're big and
famous
right and uh go to timcast.com become a
member we're gonna have an exclusive
members only segment coming up in about
an hour from now so
thanks so much for all of you hanging
out leave us a good review on itunes
spotify if you haven't already
or check it out there if you'd like you
can follow me on all social media
platforms at tim cast
and my other youtube channels are
youtube.comtimcastnyoutube.comcastnews
this show is live monday friday at 8pm
so we'll be back tomorrow night did you
want to mention
uh your books maybe hold them up and
show people jim yeah
buy my books yeah because i will use the
money to go back in time and kill baby
hitman
he's an honest man and i'll buy apple
stock so i have more money when i come
back bitcoin yeah
and bitcoin winning the second civil war
without firing a shot and the myth of
white fragility
they both kick ass right on you have
social media you want to mention as well
jim hansen dc but when you go there i'm
grayed out because twitter is evil
and jack dorsey is some kind of cleric
in
in a bad game of dungeon i did see your
your picture when i went to your page
you got to fight through the filters to
get there not that i ever violated the
rules but because
twitter is a gutless company that
believes in
social media credit scores and i kick
their butt and arguments too much
jim i'm glad you came i'm glad you
existed it's really cool meeting you man
dude i'm glad you exist because we need
to question things
yeah and you're a questioner yes that is
true i'm on a quest
the basis of my life is the question
yourself uh thanks guys i'm ian
crossland you get me at ian
crossland.net
and uh connect with me on social media
there and if you are interested in this
open source project that we're working
on message me on twitter
and um i'll see if i can set you up with
our chat room from there very cool and
i'm sour patch lids i push buttons in
the corner for a living it's a great job
i wouldn't trade it for anything
i love our guests especially jim that is
a very cool looking book that i need to
read as soon as you uh this is what i
have time
um i'm sarah patchell it's on twitter
and mines and real sour patch lids on
gavin instagram
also it's a great shirt we're in the
watson shirt yeah super cool
all right everybody we will be back in
the exclusive members only segment at
timcast.com so become a member and we
will see you all there
you